Tausende Hipster, diese üblichen spacken Nasen, verbringen jeden Tag im Internet. Und wenn da euer Gerät da rein steckt, dann habt ihr auch heute. Ohne eigentlich zu verstehen, wie das alles funktioniert. Wir haben Tier 10 Megabit bestellt! Nee, das Internet ist ihr scheiß Arbeitswerk. Es ärgert mich jetzt langsam. Ihr könnt noch mal ein Minimum von dem verstehen, Watzelot, mit diesen absoluten Basics. Lerne endlich IP. Warum macht man es richtig? Ich gehe da auch schon. Freak Show hören hilft. Ja, der Router da hinten. Nein, das ist ein Access Point.
Also sozusagen diese Kopplung deines Daten- und Programmmodells mit einem User-Interface, was da deine Webseite ist.
Das heißt, wenn dir Daten reinströmen und sich dann in deinem Model was ändert, dann update sich halt der View gleich so automatisch mit dran.
Genau, wenn du das möchtest.
Und ist das dann so Model-View-Controller-mäßig oder was? Na ja, ohne Einschränkungen. Weil View und Controller halt oft in diesen Frameworks so verschmelzen. Und ein Model ist dann meistens mit irgendwelchen Ajax-Calls auch noch an andere Datenquellen rangeklebt, aber repräsentiert dann halt so ein JSON-Objekt, was dann eben immer wieder geupdatet werden kann. Und dann kannst du halt sagen, hier, diese Property oder dieses Ding ist jetzt an diese View-Komponente gebunden. Und wenn sich da die Daten ändern, dann updatet sich der View gleich automatisch in die eine oder andere Weise. Ich hab ja gar nicht mit Angular oder React zu tun gehabt, sondern bisher nur für kleines Projektive-Backbone-JS benutzt, was sozusagen so eine sehr minimalistische Implementation davon ist. Aber so in etwa würde ich mir das bei den anderen beiden auch vorstellen.
Und eigentlich kannst du sie auch nicht wirklich miteinander vergleichen. Ich mach seit über einem Jahr ein Newsletter über Angular. Und da ist jede Woche irgendein, könnte ich in einen Artikel reinnehmen, Angular vs. React. Was ist jetzt, was nimmt man jetzt?
Ach du machst, wenn du sagst, du machst ein Newsletter, du schreibst ihn.
Ja, schreiben ist jetzt zu gut, das sind halt Links drin. Ich erstelle ihn.
Du erstellst den Inhalt einer Mail. Ist der ja public oder ist der nur so für Eingeweihte? Ich weiß ja nicht. Vielleicht hast du ja da so deine geheime Angular-Possi.
Du kannst ihn gerne abonnieren. Ich weiß ihn nicht. Geh mal auf bit.ly slash Äh ja, sorry. Der andere ist eigentlich schöner. Ich hab noch ein Web VR Newsletter. Genau, und da könnte ich jede Woche einen Artikel reintun, weil Leute irgendwie jetzt wissen wollen, ob React oder Angular cooler ist. Und ich würde sagen, das ist wie immer. Du musst halt beim Projekt gucken, was irgendwie mehr Sinn macht. Und Angular ist so, dass es also die zweite Version von Angular, das heißt jetzt nur noch Angular, nicht mehr AngularJS und auch nicht Angular 2, sondern nur noch Angular. Und da kommt halt so alles zusammen. Also du hast irgendwie den Router gleich mit dabei und das Templating-Modul und Form-Module und so. Und kannst irgendwie Reactive schreiben mit Observables. Und bei React ist es glaube ich eher so, wie gesagt, ich hab's nie benutzt, bei React ist es glaube ich eher so, dass du einen ziemlich kleinen React-Library hast. Und wenn du dann jetzt irgendwie noch Reactive schreiben willst, dann nimmst du dir noch irgendwie Redux dazu und also so, also dann musst du dir mehr so zusammensuchen. Kannst aber vielleicht individueller. Also so hab ich das immer verstanden, deswegen sollte man es vielleicht auch gar nicht vergleichen.
Also Angular ist sozusagen das alles schon zusammengewickelte und bei React... Und React ist eher so ein Komponenten-Baukasten.
React ist halt klein. Und du kannst es mit vielen anderen Libraries zusammen benutzen. Und jeder schreibt irgendwie eine kleine Komponente und dann etabliert sich mal eine Komponente und man nimmt dann irgendwie für Internationalization nur noch die Komponente und für Styling die und...
Und das Angular ist sowas... Das kennst du jetzt vielleicht nicht so, das Ruby on Rails, wo irgendwie alles, was man für eine Web-App schon brauchen könnte, gleich mitkommt?
Das ist was für alte Leute.
Du ey, das ist das Jahr, das 21. Jahrhundert, du kannst dir nicht vorstellen, wie viele Leute jetzt immer noch so, also Ruby on Rails, also das muss es jetzt sein.
Und wenn es zu Apps kommt, dann hast du bestimmt an React Native gedacht?
Das kann sein, ja.
Wo dann irgendwie, dann schreibst du React, aber es kommt eine native App bei raus. Da kommt, also du schreibst, da sind glaube ich keine Webviews drin, wenn du es nicht haben willst.
Also er überletzt das in die OS-Views, okay.
Genau, und auf der Angular-Seite gibt es da eben NativeScript. Ja, genau, und mit NativeScript kannst du... Aber das gibt es halt in Äquivalent, auch auf der Angular-Seite, die man gut benutzen kann. Und ein großer Unterschied ist noch, dass du bei Angular, glaube ich, TypeScript meistens schreibst.
Ja, das ist in der zweiten, also in der neueren Version jetzt der Fall, ne?
Du kannst auch Dart oder JavaScript, du kannst ES5 und ES6 auch schreiben, aber die meisten schreiben TypeScript.
Ja, ich hörte, dass es großartig sein soll.
TypeScript?
Es ist von Microsoft so ein JavaScript.
Ja, was typisiert ist dann. Und darauf gehen viele ziemlich ab. Muss ich mir bei Gelegenheit auch mal anschauen.
Eine durch Microsoft entwickelte Programmiersprache, die auf den Vorschlägen zum zukünftigen ECMAScript 6 Standard basiert. Warum nimmt man dann nicht einfach den?
Weil ECMAScript 6 ja auch nicht typisiert. Also das erzwingt ja keine Typisierung. Und wie gesagt, man schreibt ja JavaScript nicht so, dass man jetzt irgendwie jede Zeit den Typen wechselt. Aber bei TypeScript kann man es halt entforcen oder man nimmt den All-Typen.
Ja, aber das verstehe ich, diese ganze Typisierung vom JavaScript und diese Annäherung an so Java-ismen, die verstehe ich ja irgendwie auch nicht so ganz. Also die Sprache wird irgendwie auch nicht cooler dadurch, oder?
Das ist eine Klasse jetzt.
Ach ja, stimmt, das gibt's ja jetzt auch, genau. Naja, das wird sich ja vielleicht bald mit der WebASM-Welt ändern.
Das ist auch meine Hoffnung.
Ja, JSX schreibt noch eine, das ist natürlich cool bei React.
Was ist das?
Ich hab dich mit dem Foto aus dem Frontend, glücklicherweise, aber ja.
Redet zu uns.
Wo schreibst du Tags eigentlich?
Wo schreibst du Tags? Entschuldigung, fang mal von vorne an.
Im JavaScript.
Ja, dann machst du wann wo was?
Da kannst du dann Tags schreiben, also bei React Tags mit dreieckigen Klammern. Und das übersetzt das dann wiederum in JavaScript zurück. Also ich könnte jetzt eher...
Das ist alles so ein...
Deswegen ist React VR dann eben auch vergleichsweise ultra einfach im Gegensatz, wenn man jetzt pur WebGL oder selbst mit einer Library FreeJS schreibt, weil man braucht halt irgendwie eine Zeile, in dem man schreibt pano tag und dann mache ich meine Ressource zu dem Panorama Bild rein und dann übersetzt es das im Hintergrund in eine WebGL Szene mit einer Kamera, mit einem Licht, mit einer Kugel...
Also ist das eine Mark-up-Sprache quasi innerhalb des... Oder so eine Makrosprache. Ey, wildes Zeug da an diesem Frontend, nicht?
Da bist du zu alt für den Scheiß, hm?
Na, ich hab mich ja in meiner Zeit immer weiter vom Frontend entfernt und wurde immer glücklicher dabei. Insofern, immer wenn ich gefragt werde, willst du nicht nochmal wieder Frontend machen? Du hast das doch auch früher gemacht, so lehne ich dankend ab. Da komm ich jetzt auch nicht mehr rein in diesen Wooster.
Das ist auch wirklich ein Krokodilsteig, also...
Das denkt man ja, wenn man zwei Wochen Urlaub war, dass man nicht mehr reinkommt.
Und du machst eine Menge Urlaub, oder? Gefühlt machst du eine Menge Urlaub.
Gefühlt zu wenig.
Also ich finde auch, da muss einfach mal wieder ein bisschen Stringenz reinkommen in dieses ganze Spiel. Was wolltest du womöglich sagen?
Dass Stringenz rein muss.
Das Frontend das fasert doch alles aus. Ich meine, da ist irgendwie nichts mehr klar. Alles ist irgendwie so voodoo. Man weiß nicht so genau, was man targetet. Man weiß irgendwie nicht, ist alles so total offen. Und dann halt auch noch so dieses skurrile Rennen zwischen Native und Web. Was auch immer wieder so hin und her schaukelt. Kann man auch sagen, okay, Survival of the fittest. Und da kann sich dann irgendwie auch was draus ergeben. Man muss ja auch sagen, da sind auch eine ganze Menge Strategien dahinter. Ich will jetzt keine großen Verschwörungstheorien hier aufmachen. Aber so React, so als der, mach doch deine App in React. Dann bist du von allem entkoppelt. Dann musst du irgendwie nicht mehr iOS machen und dann musst du nicht mehr Android denken, sondern du schreibst halt irgendwie deine Anwendung mit React Native und dann rendern wir dir das dann schon irgendwie, dass das dann eben so eine App ist, die durch einen Store kommt.
Und du kannst im Web und in der App dieselben Module benutzen, zum Beispiel Airbnb macht das glaube ich so. Du hast halt eine Code-Basis.
Und den Appeal verstehe ich auch irgendwie total. Nur ist halt sozusagen die Frage, wer ist denn dann der nächste Plattform-Meister? Also kriegen wir jetzt Facebook sozusagen auch noch auf der Ebene auch nochmal komplett übergestöbt, dann ist ja...
Das ist halt bei den Open Source-Projekten so, dass die, ja, die, die man benutzen will, wo man weiß, das ist ja immer eine Abwägungssache. Wenn ich jetzt eine Library benutze, wo ein Typ drin schreibt, will ich vielleicht nicht mein Airbnb damit bauen.
Das ist aufverständlich.
Ja, genau. Und deswegen verlassen sich glaube ich, deswegen springen dann immer Leute, wenn sie sehen, ok, das ist jetzt von Facebook, dann weiß ich, das wird vielleicht noch ein paar Jahre lang entwickelt. Ja, das ist glaube ich so eine Standard-Überlegung. Aber es ist ja jetzt zum Beispiel auch dieses Wo kennst du das, was jetzt irgendwie noch so auf den Platz gekommen ist?
Das sagt mir was, ich glaube, ich habe es mal irgendwo gesehen und dann aha und weggeklickt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das richtig ausspreche. V-O-E? Genau, das ist, das ist...
Koffe-Fist.
Programmieren Sie doch einen Koffe-Fist.
Das ist, glaube ich, auch von einem nur. Und wird jetzt auch von vielen... Von vielen tatsächlich eingesetzt. Und da steckt, glaube ich, keine Riesenfirma dahinter. Aber im 3D ist das auch so. Also alle Anwendungen, die ich kenne, oder 90% der Anwendungen, die ich kenne, und auch sowas wie React VR oder das Pendant von Mozilla, A-Frame, die beruhen alle, haben alle als Dependency 3JS.
Ja, das ist ja so, der die Part bestanden hat.
Und das ist halt von Ricardo aus Spanien und zwei weiteren Contributoren. Ich frage mich halt, was passiert mit dem 3D-Web, wenn der mal keinen Bock mehr drauf hat?
Ich könnte echt mal so eine Übersicht gebrauchen. Ja, also ich meine, was da überhaupt von wozu? Um da einfach mal wieder so einen Überblick zu bekommen.
Da gab es so eine coole Webseite, wo du sozusagen, was willst du machen? Und da gab es so diverse Buttons, die du so anklickst. Und dann hat er dir sozusagen reingefiltert, welche Frameworks dafür in Frage kommen. Nur leider habe ich die URL gar nicht im Kopf. Die war auch total bunt und so. So wie man sich das vorstellt für so Frontend-Bling-Bling. Und die hatten wirklich eine unfassbar lange Liste. Und das war schon vor fünf Jahren oder so, als ich das mal angeschaut habe. Das ist bestimmt jetzt wirklich unendlich. Mist, wie war denn das?
Ionix sind aber, glaube ich, Webviews im Gegensatz zu NativeScript, kann das sein?
Also Ionix wurde jetzt auch noch als Framework genannt.
Genau, aber das ist kein nativer Code, der rauskommt im Gegensatz zu den anderen beiden NativeScriptern.
Hier ist auch von Web-Apps die Rede, ja.
Ja genau. Aber so vom UI sind die, glaube ich, recht performant und ganz cool auch irgendwie angepasst. Aber ja, es ist trotzdem noch eine Web-App im Gegensatz zu.
Ich frage mich halt immer, worauf man sich dann sozusagen einlässt. Also ich meine, das sind ja dann auch so richtig Plattform-Entscheidungen, weil du kriegst ja deinen Code auch nicht so ohne weiteres von dem einen ins andere wieder gezogen, oder? Also gar nicht, überhaupt nicht. Einmal Angular, immer Angular, ist das so?
Einmal sogar von einmal AngularJS, aber nicht Angular 2. Da gab es auch Breaking-Changes und ja.
Na Breaking-Changes, das kann schon mal bei einer Major-Revision auf jeden Fall sein. Aber wenn halt sich alles ändert, zum Beispiel, als ich hier meinen kleinen Bookmarking-Service mal gehackt hatte, das war ja, da hatte ich hier eben Backbone.js für benutzt. Und das hätte ich nie einfach in irgendein anderes Framework überführen können. Das hätte ich einfach komplett neu schreiben können, egal welches andere Framework ich benutzt hätte. Und das trifft, glaube ich, auf jedes Framework da draußen zu, weil jeder natürlich so seine Opinion hat, wie das zu sein hat und wie das sein müsste und sein eigener Namespace hat.
Aber du musst halt, du kannst glaube ich nicht sagen, für jedes JavaScript-Projekt nehme ich bestenfalls das Framework, sondern geh mal nach Projekt, schauen, was ist dir wichtig, wie lange soll das Projekt leben.
Ja, und wer kann das vor allem? Ich meine, oft hast du ja eher das Problem, dass du den nicht so groß aussuchen kannst, wen du halt kriegst. Und jeder hat so andere Gaben und Vorlieben und tralala. Das kennt man ja schon auch bei Programmiersprachen und so. Das ist ja im Web, kann man immerhin noch von Glück reden, in Anführungsstrichen, dass da irgendwie so, man muss mit JavaScript, mit HTML und CSS klarkommen, weil sonst läuft da halt in dem Business irgendwie gar nichts. Nur, wie das dann eben geschrieben ist, ist nochmal eine ganz andere Geschichte. Und das läuft ja dann schon auf so, ist ja schon fast wie ein anderes Betriebssystem, wenn du irgendwie so komplett andere Framework-Welten reinläufst. Gut, ist dann halt wahrscheinlich so. WebASM, habt ihr davon schonmal Wind bekommen?
Ich hab irgendwo einen Link rumflattern sehen, wahrscheinlich bei Huckel.
Wir hatten das mal in der Sendung schon ein, zwei Mal.
Ja, wir haben es schon mal so ein bisschen erwähnt, dass es das gibt. Und ich hab es mir neulich mal etwas näher angeschaut, mit der Betonung auf etwas.
Nachdem wir gesprochen hatten darüber?
Ich glaube, als wir gesprochen hatten. Dann hab ich halt angefangen, mich mal so ein bisschen hinterherzulesen und ein paar Dinge zu verstehen. Und ich würde jetzt noch nicht so weit gehen, dass ich alles begriffen habe, aber ich habe so schwer den Eindruck, dass das in die richtige Richtung geht. Dass wir also hier wirklich mit WebASM im Prinzip genau die Plattformen bekommen, die das Web halt einfach unabhängig macht von JavaScript. Also zeitwirts. Weil das kann einfach nicht sein, dass man so ein mega Ökosystem wie das Web mit einer einzigen Poamiersprache fährt. Und diese ganzen Frameworks sind eigentlich auch Ausdruck dieser Hilflosigkeit. Also Leute haben sehr, sehr, sehr unterschiedliche Targets, sehr, sehr unterschiedliche Größenordnungen, sehr, sehr unterschiedliche Teamgrößen und sehr unterschiedliche Fundings mit sehr unterschiedlichen Laufzeiten. Und auch eben dann damit verbunden auch unterschiedliche Komplexitäten, die mal vom großen mal von kleinen Teams gemacht werden muss. Und eine Poamiersprache ist jetzt nicht die einzige Variable, die an der Stelle helfen kann, aber definitiv ist das so einer der Punkte. Also könnte man ein bestimmtes Problem einfach in einer anderen Poamiersprache machen, dann hätte man halt einfach mal schon viel nicht so. Und ich zucke so als Privatprogrammierender, zucke ich halt für JavaScript einfach schon deshalb zurück, weil mir das einfach zu am Bigges ist. Also mir ist einfach diese Sprache zu matschig.
Ja, wobei sie jetzt ja mit diesen ganzen neuen ECMA-Script-Standards das ja versuchen, alles in den Zaum, also so einzuzäunen und einzugrenzen und zu typisieren und bla bla bla und auch diese Prototype-Vererbungssystem oder wie auch immer, das jetzt durch mit so einem Klaas-Konstrukt noch drüber zu schlumpfen, damit das irgendwie jetzt allen wieder gerade im Hirn das Denken ermöglicht. Aber ja, also ich habe auf jeden Fall auch das Gefühl, dass es das nicht wirklich besser macht.
Aber nur weil man wurschtlich schreiben kann, heißt es ja nicht, dass man es machen sollte. Also du musst ja nicht schlecht einen Code schreiben, nur weil es die Sprache zulässt.
Aber die anderen tun es halt dann. Du benutzt halt deren Code und dann hast du halt den Quatsch.
Die anderen machen immer nur Mist, egal wo, was man tut.
Ja, aber nur Mist, soweit es halt eine Sprache auch zulässt.
Ja, deswegen haben wir ja vorhin über das Linting gesprochen. Du musst halt irgendwie dein Projekt irgendwie im Griff haben.
Tja, dann kommen wir jetzt sozusagen auf die Remedies zu sprechen. Linting, sehr schönes Wort. Weißt du, wo es herkommt? Ja, oder irgendjemand.
Linting?
Naja, so Lind.
Ja, ich bilde mir ein, das auch schon mal nachgeguckt zu haben, aber kein Bild, kein Ton.
Unix.
Fussel.
Ja, Lind heißt Fussel, genau. Und Fluzenfilter sozusagen. Und Lint ist halt, Unix ist eines der ältesten Unix-Toolsets, was halt so mit dem C-Compiler, mit dem CC, irgendwann Lind. Und Lind ging halt irgendwie durch deinen C-Code durch und hat halt so versucht, die schlimmsten Dinge ausfindig zu machen. Und Linting ist jetzt quasi so der verallgemeinerte Prozess, nach dem Motto, ich bin jetzt zwar kein Compiler, und es geht jetzt hier nicht um klarer Fehler, sondern es geht um dieses so, ist das wirklich das, was du möchtest oder willst du nicht lieber was anderes machen? Was gibt's denn da in der Java-Scriptwelt, was hilft?
Ja, benutze ich, wenn ich, also es gab jetzt ein Projekt, da hatten die das, also normalerweise hat man irgendwie ein Linting-Fall, die sind dann vielleicht nicht besonders streng eingestellt, wie wir vorhin hatten mit, ich darf höchstens zweimal verschachteln oder eine Komplexität von dem und dem haben, sondern vielleicht irgendwie lockerer, vergisst das Semikolon nicht, aber...
Ist das jetzt so ein Tool, was du so ab und zu mal auf den Prodruf...
Das ist ein Dot-File, das legt man ins Projekt.
Und dann?
Und dann entforst du einen Bildprozess, dass einmal der Lint, das Linting durchgelaufen hat und in den Projekten, die wir aufgesetzt hatten, gibt es eben keinen Einchecken und...
Kannst du mal versuchen, so ein bisschen da zu... Also ehrlich gesagt, ich bin ja immer noch so ein VR-Mensch, wenn ich mit einer Proamiersprache anfange, dann starte ich als erstes VI.
Und das Terminal. Und im Terminal sind rote Felder, wenn das Linting nicht läuft. Oder in deinem Editor, der sagt dir auch mit einem roten Ausrufezeichen, hier Semikool und... Ja, da habe ich mich auch schon gefragt, was man da so benutzt.
Das ist für Tim schon modernes Zeug.
Ja, ja, das ist Voodoo.
Und in Vim, der jetzt ja sogar Concurrency hat und so weiter, also so richtig voll modern und so, da gibt es natürlich auch so für alle möglichen Sprachen dieses Planeten-Module, wo du sagen kannst, hier sag mir Syntax-Fehler, sag mir quasi Linting-Fehler, also oder Style-Fehler sozusagen an und der blendet dir das im Terminal, in ASCII auch schön ein. Also, koloriertes ASCII, also mit, wie heißt das dann, mit diesen Farb-, nicht Escape Sequences, sondern weißt schon Terminal-Farben und so. Das geht dann auch in Vim. Und dann wird dir das eingeblendet, wenn du Syntax-Fehler machst oder wenn du eben Style-Fehler machst.
Ich glaube, ich hatte noch nie ein Farbsetting in meinem Editor.
Ja, da hat mir ein Kollege, den ich schon ein paar Mal erwähnt hatte und sich schon beschwert hat, dass ich ihn lange nicht mehr erwähnt habe, dem habe ich beim Go-Programm, als ich damit angefangen habe, ein bisschen über die Schulter geschaut. Und der hatte nämlich auch kein Syntax-Highlighting. Und meinte, so ein modernes Zeug brauche ich nicht. Und dann hat er mir ein Bild geschickt, was ich hier dann nochmal teilen möchte. Ich suche das mal gerade kurz raus. Syntax-Highlighting. Und das glaube ich genau du. Also spiegelt das wieder.
Terminator.
Mal sehen, ich hoffe, Google findet das jetzt sofort. Ja, genau.
Das bist du quasi.
Also die eine Seite davon. Und da ist in der Meter eben Freak Show Chat. Dieses Bild hatte er mir geschickt, als ich kommentierte, dass er ja gar kein Syntax-Highlighting in seinem Editor verwenden würde.
Also links der Terminator in schwarz-weiß. Und rechts ein sehr koloriertes Vehikel.
Ist das so klar? Ja, also ich bin auf jeden Fall auch ein Syntax-Highlighter und Farbe im Editor ist toll. Aber Tim kukeltiert ja immer, dass er programmiert, aber so richtig programmieren tust du ja nun auch nicht, oder?
Was ist denn richtig programmieren, der...
Mal so irgendwas delivern, so richtig Software-shippen, die läuft und nicht nur so ein bisschen rum experimentieren und mal eine Funktion hinklimpern, die so...
Software, die läuft, na ja, ich meine, mein Steuerexport-Script läuft super!
Wie viel zahlen?
Ohne Syntax Highlighting würde ich auch nicht mehr.
Schreibst du einen Pfeil wahrscheinlich auch noch. Wieder ist nix. Das hab ich dreimal neu geschrieben, bis es immer kleiner wurde, ja natürlich.
Ist ja okay, aber das ist ja noch... Ich hab dich vor allem dreimal neu... Ich sag ja nicht, das ist ein Betriebssystem, was ich programmiere.
Ich programmier halt nach meinem eigenen Bedarf.
Und in welcher Programmiersprache? Es geht schon, aber mit Syntax-Highlighting ist halt auch nicht schlimm.
Ne, ich hab das ja in meinem Textmater hab ich natürlich auch. Syntax-Highlighting, das hilft schon. Ich hab bloß in meinem VI halt irgendwie keins.
Okay, aber du hast es in Textmater gehackt und nicht in VI.
Ich hab bloß im Wesentlichen Textmater gehackt, klaro. Ja, aber das ist schon ein richtiges Programmieren. Ich hab mich sehr intensiv mit der Programmiersprache auseinandergesetzt.
Aber du hast es nicht in VI gemacht, sondern in Textmater mit Syntax-Highlighting. Insofern, dass darum ging es ja.
Und es ging auch eigentlich darum, ob man JavaScript selber schreiben kann.
Klammer zu, Klammer zu.
Eigentlich wollte ich mal hören, was ist, sagen wir mal, so, wenn man jetzt so was macht wie du, also so seriöses Frontend entwickeln, was ist denn da so das Toolset, was man da so an den Start bringt? Also was brauchst du auf deiner Büchse oder in deinem Cloud-Server, der das irgendwie alles im Hintergrund macht? Also was wirfst du da zusammen? Also was benutzt du?
Ich benutze JavaScript und einen Compiler, der aus ES6, ES5 Code macht.
Weil?
Weil das dann in den meisten Browsern läuft.
In den meisten, was mit denen, wo es nicht läuft?
Ja, nee, das läuft in allen.
So weit sind wir schon?
ES5 läuft in allen.
Ja, wir sind so weit, dass ES5 in allen läuft. Okay, also bei dem Blick sage ich nicht nein.
Genau und ja, irgendwas zum CSS-Kompilen, weil man, ich schreibe meistens SAS, ein Editor, Terminal, mehr brauch ich nicht.
Und ein Linter hast du gesagt.
Ja, gut, man hat ja irgendeinen Bildprozess, der die Sachen kompilt, der Linter, der vielleicht Tests durchlaufen lässt. Wo alles herkommt, das schreibt man selbst und klaut sich zusammen. Oder lässt es irgendwo her, Bootstrappen oder…
Okay, aber ich meine, was genau stößt den an? Sind das jetzt irgendwie Shell-Skripts, die du da zusammenballerst? Oder ist das irgendwie…
Das sind ja Terminal, NPM-Skripts meistens.
In denen kann man auch nochmal Skript schreiben. In Java-Skript.
Kann das glaube ich auch, ja. Du kannst aus Node.js raus und Bash-Dinge anstoßen. Das hab ich auch schon gemacht.
Okay, das ist ja dann doch immer noch so wie früher.
Ja, es fühlt sich nicht sauber an.
Ich weiß nicht, früher habe ich immer Make benutzt.
Ja, das gibt es doch aber auch mit ESX. Irgendwas kannte ich da ein, der das im Projekt gemacht hat, alles mit Make files dann.
Ja, also Make gibt es immer und wird es wahrscheinlich auch immer geben. Das ist halt auch total sprachenunabhängig oder sonst was unabhängig. Das ist ja eigentlich im Prinzip nur so ein... hier unter diesem Befehl verbirgt sich eigentlich diese Kette von...
Ja, aber diese ganzen Dependencies zu schreiben, das macht man ja irgendwie auch nicht mehr. Also ich meine, so Make-Files schreiben, das gehört ja auch schon eher zu den Old-Farts-Technologies, oder? Also ich meine, auch ein Make-File, wenn man sich heute bestenfalls noch generieren lassen. Ich dachte nur, man wäre vielleicht schon langsam mal darüber hinaus und es gibt jetzt irgendwie mal so ein Bilding-Environment, was einfach noch kommt.
Also wenn du so im Team arbeitest, dann hast du halt deinen Bild-Server und so der latest greatest hippe Scheiß ist sowas wie Concourse heißt das. Kannst ja mal kurz gucken, da ist bestimmt so ein Demoscreen, da kannst du halt komplette Workflows auch visuell darstellen und sagen, wenn ich auf GitHub, auf den Master pushe oder einen Pull-Request stelle, dann checkt den Code aus, lass die Tests laufen, lass den Linter laufen, wenn alles grün ist, trag das bei GitHub ein, damit der Pull-Request grün ist. Oder wenn du einen Release in... Dann hast du hier so deine Workflow-Grafik und kannst dann halt sagen, auch wenn ich einen Release mache auf GitHub, also einen Tag, einen Release-Tag mache und das pushe, dann kommt der nächste Workflow, der das auf Staging deploys und eine Image baut und noch irgendwie andere Checks laufen lässt und auch automatisch gleich auf deine Cloud deploit und so. Und das wäre halt für so ein Team-Workflow, wo du eh so ein Git-Repo hast und da alle hin committen und Pull-Requests und so weiter. Und dann hast du eben da diesen Build-Server, der alles orchestriert und da kannst du deine Workflows auch abbilden und der sagt dir dann zum Beispiel bei deinem Pull-Request, Alter, du hast da Trailing New Lines in deinem Fall und zwar 25 Stück, mach die mal weg, sonst lass ich den Pull-Request nicht grün werden. Also je nachdem, was dein Style-Gard oder dein Linter halt dann für Regeln enforced, das ist ja dann dir überlassen noch, aber das ist halt manchmal einfach auch ein bisschen bescheuert weil oft sich die Leute gar nicht so Gedanken machen und denken so, wir brauchen einen Linter und wir brauchen einen Style-Guide, aber den dann nicht hinterfragen, sondern einfach irgendeinen nehmen und dann kämpft das ganze Team dagegen an, was dann oft dazu führt, dass der irgendwann abgeschaltet wird, statt sich damit auseinanderzusetzen. Aber genau, das wäre ein so ein Beispiel, wo man nicht nur Frontend, sondern auch Backend und alles irgendwie zusammen hacken kann.
Das mach ich bei meiner Webseite zum Beispiel, oder wenn ich so Sachen für Kunden hosten muss mit CodeShip. Aber ja, in großen Projekten schreibt dieses Bild, diesen Bildprozess schreibt ja da nicht der. CodeShip ist auch so ein CI-Zeug. In so riesen Projekten... Ja, in so großen Projekten macht den Bildprozess ja nicht irgendwie der Frontend-Entwickler, sondern da sagt man dann, dass man haben will, und dann macht das irgendwie einen Dev-Op, der irgendwo rumhockt und sonst nichts umhört. Im Keller meistens, lockig.
Also früher hat man halt Jenkins benutzt. Jetzt gibt es halt 1000 neue Tools, gerade so eine neue Welle von CI und Bildtools, die gerade die Runde macht. Weil Jenkins, jetzt auch in der neuesten Version, die haben ja noch mal einiges geändert, aber es ist halt auch noch so ein riesiges Java-Wrack-Projekt. Die neue ist ja jetzt besser geworden, aber es ist immer noch so ein Flugzeugträger von Software halt.
Was ist mit Travis CI? War das nicht so der Urvater von dem ganzen?
Nee, das ist nicht der Urvater.
Was ist denn der Urvater?
Also, dass sie nicht ablenken. Also was der Urvater für Continuous Integration ist, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt jetzt nicht, weil zu der Zeit, als ich da in Ruby on Rails und so Zeit noch unterwegs war, da gab es ganz viele kleine Projekte und Jenkins gab es glaube ich schon auch. Und Travis CI, die Geschichte ist ja eigentlich die, dass der Herr Sven Fuchs, auch so ein Ruby-Hacker früher Zeiten, der irgendwann mal keinen Bock mehr hatte auf seinen Job und dann sich vom Arbeitsamt mal kurz so ein bisschen hat durchfüttern lassen und in der Zeit dachte, weißt du was richtig cool wäre, wenn es halt so Open Source Projekte einfach so einen Cloud-CI geben und hat angefangen es zu hacken und irgendwie haben dann die GitHub-Leute das auch gleich gesehen oder haben sich mit dem gleich gut verstanden und dann wurde das halt zu diesem großen Ding, was jetzt viele benutzen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht der Urvater, also davor gab es das schon ganz lange. Ja, das ist im Prinzip sowas wie Jenkins auch. Also Hudson und Jenkins, das sind glaube ich so mit die Ältesten von dieser Geschichte.
Oh Gott, das ist ja wirklich ein Wirrware.
Ja, Jenkins ist aus Hudson entstanden, genau so rum war das. Und davor habe ich ehrlich gesagt dann noch wenig Ahnung. Bei der Rubi-Welt, da gab es dann viele so eigen gehackte Dinge.
Setzst du dir sowas auch immer für deine Prototypen auf?
Nee, gar nicht. Also meine Prototypen sind wirklich Angular, Node und D3.
Und musst du es dann irgendwo hosten auch? Weil ich frag mich halt immer, ab wann es sich lohnt, für mich das einzusetzen.
Also jetzt bei dem aktuellen Projekt hat sich wohl jemand dazu breitschlagen lassen, dass wir den Prototyp mindestens zwei oder fünf Jahre hosten danach. Ja, also müsste man dann halt mal machen. Aber da weiß ich jetzt auch noch nicht, was wir überhaupt alles haben werden. Da bin ich einfach noch nicht so weit, dass ich weiß, was ich einsetzen werde. Weil da auch noch mit der Datenstruktur das größere Problem gerade besteht. Was für eine Datenbank ich da nehme. Das ist mein größeres Problem als dieses Continuous Integration. Es kann sein, dass am Ende doch nur wieder eine Datenbank, die über Angular angesprochen wird, auch gleich in dem Ökosystem mitläuft. Und in einem anderen Projekt.
Das heißt, du bist nicht so in der Linter-Fraktion?
Ich hab den Linter in der Tat auf meinem Webstorm laufen. Weil ich bin ja der faule Mensch und hab mir irgendwann mal dieses wunderbare Software-Tool von IntelliJate, glaube ich, gekauft. Die Webstorm-IDI. Wo du halt einfach schon so ein paar Dinge dabei hast. Also die machen einfach das Leben leichter.
Aber du hast da auch so einen Java-Panzer unter der Haube, ne?
Ja, jetzt schwimpfe ich schon wieder auf meinen Java-Panzer. Ich nutze ihn in der Tat auch nicht für alles. Also ich würde nie nur mit Webstorm arbeiten können. Ich nutze halt auch auf jeden Fall immer noch Sublime. Also ich nutze Webstorm, Sublime. Jetzt musste ich den Emacs mal wieder herauskramen, weil er...
Also Sublime ist der Editor auf Mac.
Auch auf Windows und Windows.
Richtig, der war ja Cross-Plattform.
Genau, und halt Terminal. Also das ist so mein Ökosystem, in dem ich rumhause, je nachdem, was ich halt so brauche gerade. Aber mit Continuous Integration, das habe ich in meinem ersten Job, glaube ich, haben wir da viel gemacht, weil das ja irgendwie wirklich eine größere Software war, die wir geschrieben haben, und da gab es halt auch so Codeformater, der immer wieder drüber gelaufen ist, dann den Linter. Aber das ist eine gute Frage, wann lohnt sich das dann halt auch einzusetzen? Aber ich weiß, da haben wir auch kurz drüber gesprochen, was mich ärgert, dass ich einfach noch viel zu wenig weiß über Codetesting in JavaScript. Weil ich meine, es kann auch durchaus sein, dass es ein bisschen schwieriger ist zu testen, wenn du so im Bereich der Visualisierung arbeitest. Weil du dann halt ja schon, also ich habe meine Bachelorarbeit mich auch damit beschäftigt, wie man Java-Interfaces überhaupt testen kann oder Oberflächen automatisiert testen kann, weil das halt auch nicht so ohne weiteres gut funktioniert.
Das ist ja auch das große Problem seit eh und je. Und das ist eigentlich auch der Grund, warum ich mich im Backend so wohlfühle, weil du da alles im Prinzip testen und beweisen kannst. Du kannst halt sagen, wenn das reinkommt, kommt das raus und wenn du mir das schickst, schick ich dir das zurück und das ist so und das wird auch nicht anders sein. Aber im Frontend, da hast du ja das Problem, dass sozusagen der State von deiner UI schwer formal ausdrückbar ist. Also welches Fenster ist jetzt gerade im Vordergrund, also wenn du zum Beispiel so hier so ein Betriebssystem hast, welches Fenster ist im Vordergrund, wo ist gerade der Fokus auf dem Bedienelement und das in so einem automatisierten Test herbeizuführen, ist einfach schwer und dann eben auch zu gucken, ist das Fenster jetzt an dieser Position und ist das so groß und ist der Button da und ist der Text da und dies alles. Deswegen halt ganz oft die Frontend-Tests sich ja dann eigentlich auch nur auf die Business-Logik konzentrieren ganz oft. Also so, wenn ich den Button klicke, werden dann 200 Coins im Spiel abgezogen oder so ein Zeug halt, aber selten wirklich den State der UI und das ist eigentlich immer das Schwierige. Und dann gab es ja eine Zeit lang diesen Trend, dass du so ein Webkit oder was auch immer in dein Projekt mit eincheckst und so Selenium und wie die mich alle heißen. Ob das jetzt wirklich dazu geführt hat, dass alles besser wird, weiß ich auch nicht. Ich hatte nicht das Gefühl, aber glücklicherweise musste ich mich damit auch nicht auseinandersetzen. Aber ich habe so das Gefühl, es hat sich immer noch nicht so wirklich auch so ein hundertprozentiger Weg da ergeben, wie du wirklich alles mal durchtesten kannst.
Ja gut, alles testen ist ja immer schwer. Aber ich habe zum Beispiel schon mal in einem Frontend-Projekt gearbeitet. Wo wir eher nur visuelle Tests gemacht haben und gar keine Unit-Tests, weil das Projekt so war. Das war so eine Seite für eine große Automarke. Da sind nur so SVG-Autos reingefahren, wieder rausgefahren. Die Schrift ist reingefahren und wieder raus animiert worden. Das musste aber eben auf kleinen Bildschirmen stimmen und auch auf riesen Bildschirmen. Da ist es halt immer ein bisschen schwer gewesen zu schreiben, ist es jetzt wirklich in allen Größen die Schrift noch sichtbar? Da haben wir dann schon Tests geschrieben, die eben das Browser-Fenster resized haben, die die Seite einmal durchgegangen sind und geguckt haben, ist dieser Text sichtbar? Wird der angezeigt, ist der in above the fold? Das kann man ja dann schon testen. Du musstest es dann nicht mehr manuell durchgehen und auf jedem Gerät groß und klein ziehen, sondern kannst es einmal in diesem Browser machen.
Aber auf dem Gerät, wo die Tests laufen, hast du denn dann auch alle Browser oder alle Rendering-Engines und so weiter verfügbar? Oder simuliert ihr sozusagen die Fenstergrößen?
Wir haben gesagt, wir hätten es auch in mehreren Browsern machen können. Wir haben den Firefox genommen und dann die verschiedenen Breiten eher durchgegangen, weil das halt dieser Edge-Case war.
Ich mach mal ein Fenster auf.
Der da wichtig war. Bei Linting frage ich mich gar nicht, das setze ich einfach ein. Test-driven schreibt man ja jetzt die Prototypen nicht. Und C-I frage ich mich halt noch länger und noch öfter, weil ich aber auch einfach nicht so gut bin, das dann irgendwie einzurichten, sowas wie Codechip und so.
Ja, das muss man einmal sich da durchwursteln und wenn man es dann am Laufen hat, dann ist es, also wahrscheinlich könntest du dir sogar, gibt es so bei Amazon in der Cloud schon die fertigen Images, wo du einfach nur so ein Ding hochfährst und das hat dann alles schon installiert. Aber ja, selber hosten ist natürlich sowieso noch mal viel cooler.
Ein bisschen mit mehr Aufwand verbunden, wenn man alleine der Tech-Projekt ist.
Klar, für meine eigenen Projekte habe ich auch keinen CI Server, weil ich halt dann selber die Tests einfach immer laufen lasse, aber...
Zum Beispiel bei einer Webseite, die man jetzt irgendwie fünf Jahre hat, da lohnt sich schon, dass Continuous Integration ist. Und wenn ich was auf Dev pushe, dass es dann auf dev.geildanke landet oder so. Das hat sich auf jeden Fall gelohnt.
Also spätestens, wenn man mit mehreren Leuten an einer Sache arbeitet, lohnt sich das.
Oder wenn man irgendwie monatelang nicht mehr dran gearbeitet hat und nicht mehr so genau weiß. Und dann geht es aber einfach automatisch. Browser Stack haben wir auch öfter benutzt.
Ja, das haben wir auch gehabt. Das ist wirklich wunderbar.
Und nach ATEM hat vorhin noch jemand gefragt, das hatte ich auch vor VIM benutzt.
Stimmt, du bist ja jetzt auch auf VIM umgestiegen.
Das bringt uns noch ein bisschen zu der Editor-Frage. Weil du gerade noch mal Sublime erwähnt hast. Ich fände mir auf, dass ich das auch auf meiner Platte hatte. Das war ja irgendwann mal so der Hype. Wie so jeder Editor irgendwann mal so ein bisschen seinen Hype hatte. Und es gibt ja so dermaßen viel.
Welche Version von Sublime hast du da jetzt?
Jetzt hab ich mir gerade mal die neueste runtergeladen.
Ja, naja, der ist eigentlich auch immer noch gut.
Gerade auch größere Files öffnen.
Genau, der ist immer noch ziemlich performant. Ich bin trotzdem irgendwie dann ja wieder zum Wim zurückgekehrt, weil ich festgestellt hab, die ganzen Fancy-Features, die ich jetzt auch alle so durchscrollen sehe auf diesem animierten GIF, tragen nicht. Also die benutze ich einfach so gut wie. Oder ich hab keine Use-Cases wirklich dafür. Die sehen gut aus und man staunt erstmal nicht schlecht, aber am Ende des Tages habe ich mich doch irgendwie was ich nie gedacht hätte auf diesen Vim-Modus wirklich eingeschossen und mag ihn sehr.
Also was genau hält dich da? Also benutzt du diesen Mac-Vim? Also benutzt du diesen GUI-Vim?
So wurde jetzt auch auf dem Server, im Terminal, auf dem Mac den Mac-Vim. Aber der Mac-Vim ist ja auch nur ein GUI-Rapper von Vim. Also der das Textrendering ein bisschen anders macht. Aber ansonsten, also er fällt sich ja wie ein GUI-Vim. Das heißt, du kannst halt Blinking-Cursor haben und so ein paar andere Sachen, die du im Terminal nicht so einfach bewerkstelligen kannst. Aber es ist eine relativ dünne Schicht über dem eigentlichen Vim.
Na gut, aber was ist denn jetzt, was ist denn so cool, was findest du cool an zu bleiben?
Also ja, die Größe, also dass du wirklich große Files damit aufmachen kannst. Also ich hab halt JSON-Files, die unter Umständen auch mal ein Gigabyte sein können oder größer. Ja, das ist halt so das, was du teilweise... Ich hab von der Deutschen Nationalbibliothek gerade den Dump gezogen. Das war kein JSON, hätte ich mich noch ein bisschen mehr darüber gefreut. Es ist eine XML-Formatierung, wo ein Pfeil, ich glaub das kleinste Pfeil von denen, also es sind vier Pfeils insgesamt, 16 Gigabyte ist das kleinste Pfeil von denen. 16 fuckige Gigabyte XML-Scheiße.
Naja, ich mein, es ist immerhin wohl dokumentiert.
Das, nee, die Dokumentation wollen wir jetzt nicht noch anfangen.
Wohlgeformt.
Hat sich stets bemüht. Aber da bin ich zum Beispiel an die Grenzen gestoßen. Da musste ich halt im Emacs, also hab ich das dann einfach im Emacs geöffnet, damit ich überhaupt sehen kann, was da drin ist an Daten. So einen groben Überblick zu bekommen. Das funktionierte selbst im Sublime nicht mehr. Aber diese große Dateienladung, das ja halt echt schnell ist, finde ich super. Ich nutze den in der Tat immer nur, um Files zu öffnen. Ich schreibe meine Markdown-Sachen da drin. Ich nutze das halt auch gerade für die Studis zum Präsentieren von meinem Code, weil du halt schnell irgendwie den rein- und rauszoomen kannst, was die Schrift an angeht. Wo du jetzt eben beim Web Store müsstest du in die Einstellung gehen und die Font-Size ändern und du denkst dir so, welcher Trottel hat sich denn das bitte überlegt? Also es geht halt gar nicht. Und dieses Multiple Select Mode finde ich super. Du hast einfach nur einen Text-Editor. Ich lade da auch selten meine gesamten Projekte rein, wie das viele machen. Das brauche ich einfach nicht. Ich nutze ihn wirklich so zum Files öffnen.
Aber wenn du 16 GB Files mal reingucken willst, und es soll nicht lange dauern, also im Chat meint der hier einer benutzt doch Tail, aber so Less oder sowas im Terminal, also wenn du jetzt nicht unbedingt Syntax-Highlighting brauchst, kannst du ja so Files einfach sozusagen durchpagen.
Ja, ich habe in der Tat dann mit Dings gearbeitet, mit den Bash-Befehlen, dass ich dann einfach mal geguckt habe, was da drunter läuft. Ja, warte mal, dann musst du jetzt nachgucken, wo du durch einen Pfeil durchgehen kannst und nach Dingen suchst. Oder einfach nur mit der Anzahl der Records zählen.
Das sind aber keine Bash-Befehle. Das sind einfach, also das sind Commands, die Shell heißt Bash. Das sind auch nicht die Shell-Commands, das sind tatsächlich schöne Programme, die du über die Shell aufrufst und ob das jetzt die Bash ist oder die SH oder die Z-Shell oder die Fisch, das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema.
Gut.
Und die Bash, das muss ich hier nochmal sagen, das ist ja sozusagen mein heiliger Krieg, ist die beschissenste Shell von allen. Und dass die nun ausgerechnet die weitverbreiteste ist, na gut, das haben sich ja in der technologischen Geschichte oft wiederholt, dass nicht die beste Technologie sich auf dem Massenmarkt durchsetzt, aber so viel Zeit muss sein.
Gut, wo haben wir vorher drüber geredet?
Warum es Herb Leim so toll ist. Das war, oder waren wir jetzt schon beim nächsten Thema.
Ich nutze Herb Leim auch immer so als Braindump. Also einfach nur, einfach kurz mal öffnen, irgendwelche Gedanken reinschmeißen und jahrelang offen lassen, diese Sachen. Ich weiß nicht, ich liebe es halt.
Ich habe gerade hier mal wieder so einen Praktikabilitätstest gemacht. Es ist dann auch gleich prompt dran gescheitert.
Nämlich?
Hat kein Syntax-Highlighting für CSV.
Das verstehe ich immer nicht.
Was verstehe ich denn daran nicht?
Was willst du denn da highlighten?
Das frage ich mich auch gerade.
Die Delimiter zumindest.
Da kannst du den Delimiter markieren. Und einfach mal, ich glaube, Command-Shift-D.
CSV, ich bitte dich.
Du musst den Delimiter doch setzen, weil es gibt doch tausend verschiedene Arten davon. Die heißen ja immer alle CSV. Manchmal sind es mit Tabs, manchmal sind es mit Kommas, manchmal sind es Semicolon.
Ja, und? Das kann man doch wohl erkennen, indem man sich das anschaut. Ich meine, die Datei heißt CSV.
Das macht sehr eifrig. Ne?
Das machen die alle nicht.
Welcher Editor macht das denn?
Ich benutze, auf dem Mac habe ich ein schönes kleines App Store Programm gefunden. Das heißt einfach Tabletool. Das ist jetzt mein Default für...
Ey, das ist ein spezialisiertes Tool für genau diesen Anwendungsfall. Du wirst das jetzt wohl nicht gegen alle Texteditoren dieser Welt vergleichen.
Ich finde einfach nur, wenn sie schon so rumfanzen mit irgendwie Syntax-Highlighting und wie geil sie so mit Text umgehen können, da muss man ja wohl mit CSV klarkommen können. Textmata hat CSV, kann aber natürlich nur mit Komma umgehen und nicht mit Semikolon, weil das halt von Amerikanern gemacht ist.
Aber Tim, es gibt bestimmt ein Package. Ich wollte gerade sagen, du programmierst doch jetzt so viel.
Also in Vim kann man die Limiter ersetzen. Vielleicht geht das da ja sogar.
Sublime, schätze ich mal. Sublime Text. Zwei. Nicht drei. Aber geht vielleicht trotzdem.
Ach, das muss mir bitte die alte Version, die ich gerade gelöscht habe, muss ich wieder runtergehen.
Geht vielleicht trotzdem.
Also Sublime ist jetzt gescheitert, weil es sozusagen...
Nein, ich meine, es wäre... Die Delimiter nur mit einer Tastenkombination erfahren.
Das wäre jetzt einfach cool gewesen. Ich mach die Datei auf und sie ist dann einfach...
Aber deswegen willst du ja Sublime nehmen, weil nicht jeder Scheiß schon drin ist. Sondern weil du halt dir die Pakete dann dazu holst, wie du sie brauchst und einen schlanken Editor währenddessen hast. Nicht so ein CSV-Sündungserde.
Guck mal hier, das Wim CSV-Plugin, das man installieren kann, das macht hier dann auch gleich so voll.
Den Table-Magic.
Das macht hier so gleich so richtig...
Oh, das ist ja mal ein Feature.
Aber da könntest du auch schon fast LibreOffice nutzen.
Aber das ist halt auch ein Plugin. Also das ist jetzt nicht ein Fallteil-Plugin. Wobei, ich weiß nicht, ein Fallteil-Plugin macht ja eigentlich nicht so viel.
Das war so eine Idee, da bin ich ja bisher noch gar nicht gekommen.
Ja, ich hab ja meinen Wim ja in den Dot-Files, da in meinem GitHub-Repo ja auch eigentlich ganz gut gepflegt. Ich hab auch letztens einen Kollegen damit gebootstrapped. Und der ist jetzt eigentlich auch ganz glücklicher Wim-User geworden damit. Weil da gibt's ja auch so was wie Oh My Z-Shale, wo alle Plugins tausendfach gleich, die es überhaupt nur gibt, installiert sind und man alles anhat. Und das gibt's für Wim auch. Ich hab vergessen, wie das Package heißt. Und dann hab ich irgendwann mir überlegt, was benutze ich wirklich davon und hab mir nochmal meine eigene Eindampfung davon gemacht mit den wirklich nützlichen Sachen. Also bei Wim, da geht's sowieso einfach.
Sollte man das Icon hübsch gemacht.
Und wie gesagt, also der Wim 8, der hat ja Features, Features, Features. Der ist jetzt richtig modern geworden. Also wie gesagt, eben das, zum Beispiel Plugins. Du kannst ja so Sachen machen, wie wenn du speicherst, generiert er dir die C-Tags gleich dazu, damit du immer zwischen deinen Funktionsdefinitionen und so hin und her springen kannst. Und lauter andere Sachen, die sind halt immer im Mainthread sozusagen mitgelaufen und haben sozusagen, wenn sie länger gebraucht haben, auch Syntax-Highlighting, deinen ganzen Editor zum Stillstand gebracht bisweilen, gerade bei großen Files. Und das ist jetzt bei Vim 8 alles so Asynch. Das heißt, er ist viel schnuffiger geworden.
Ist hier drunter geladen, aber...
Das müsste die 8 sein.
Die Schnuffigkeit eines Editors.
Ja, die Flubsidität.
Die darf man nicht unterschätzen. Ich möchte auch als Luapro in ihrer Ernst genommen werden, um das mal so nebenbei zu sagen.
Fühlst du dich diskriminiert?
Ein bisschen.
Warum?
Erzähl uns das doch mal, Tim.
Weil es so ist.
Also, ja, noch ganz kurz zu dem Wim-Thema. Wenn ihr jetzt so nackt daherkommt, dann fühlt sich ja wie zu Hause wie bei VI quasi. Das Syntax-Highlight, das müsste in wesentlichen schon für viele Sachen gehen, aber ich würde dir dann vielleicht auch nochmal eine individuelle Wim-Enhancement-Beratung geben, um dir so den richtigen...
Eine Wim-Enhancement-Beratung? Du könntest mir sowieso mal eine ganze Menge Command Line-Beratungen geben. Da ich ja jetzt so viel Ballast von meiner Seele geworfen habe, merke ich auch gerade, wie... Also so mein Setup verbessert sich gerade enorm im Vergleich zu den Fortschritten, die ich davor gemacht habe, die nicht existent waren. Aber jetzt bin ich gerade so offen für alles. Okay. Ich sagte dir, es gibt nichts Geileres, als eine Buchhaltung im Script zu haben. Das macht einen einfach zu einem glücklichen Menschen. Und ich habe, wie gesagt, das Script habe ich jetzt dreimal neu geschrieben. Es ist immer geiler geworden. Kürzer und geiler.
Und läuft schnell. Hast du schon geprofiled?
Meinst du noch Tests, Unit-Tests einbauen?
Nein, Profiling. Ob du noch so nicht hier und da vielleicht noch so ein paar Millisekunden weg...
Super nachlässig, würde ich sagen.
Kann ich mal gucken. Vielleicht gibt es noch so... Also beim Profiling ist ja auch das Schöne.
Das Scriptet ja im Wesentlichen, das Mani-Mani, von daher habe ich ja gar keinen Einfluss drauf. Das läuft ja nicht autark.
Ach so, du kannst es nicht separat starten. Aber ein Profiler kann auch einzelne Funktionen profilen.
Ja gut, aber auf diese Funktion habe ich ja dann keinen Zugriff. Das ist schnell genug. Ich meine, 500 Bumusätze, Export, prüpp, fertig.
Wenn man schon gerade so im Flow ist, dann will man ja noch sehen, wenn dann so ein großer Bobbel ist, der...
Ich habe mal andere, andere Eleganzen versucht zu entwickeln. Ja klar, also ich meine, ich kann jetzt auch nicht kurz schreiben, ich muss den angucken können und mich gut fühlen. Und wenn das das Richtige tut, aber scheiße aussieht, dann gehe ich da nochmal bei. Weil sonst ist es nicht okay, weil das würde ich ja dann spüren. Ich exportiere das und ich merke, dass die Daten einmal so durch so einen Schleimhaufen durchrollen. Dass es nur gerade so ebenso geht und nicht schön ist. Und jetzt merke ich immer so......alle geile Datenstruktur.
Die Daten kommen dann mit Gänsehaut raus aus dem Skript.
Der String-Parser, der macht so das Richtige. Der würde auch noch funktionieren, wenn ich mich in dem Kategoriennamen vertippt habe. Und das ist mir schon wichtig. Und vor allem ist es abgestimmt auf dieses Money-Money. Vorher hatte ich den Ansatz, ich habe so meine Kategorien und dann habe ich so meinen Skript gemacht. Dann hatte ich so Konfigurations-Datei, wie man das so macht. Konfigurations-Datei, das war eigentlich auch ganz cool, weil ich diese ganze Table-Welt von Lua so ein bisschen erst mal erfasst habe. So, wie funktioniert das? Table, was können die? Dann habe ich das ganze Typensystem erstmal begriffen. Danach habe ich festgestellt, eigentlich so Table-Konfiguration, eigentlich totaler Quatsch. Das kann ich viel besser machen. Dann wollte ich das halt quasi selbst konfigurieren. Das heißt, ich wollte alles, was quasi relevant ist für meine Anpassung, sollte überhaupt nicht in diesem Skript sein. Sondern ich wollte das komplett in Money-Money haben. Und habe da natürlich Wege gesucht, wie ich all diese ganzen Daten da rein kriege. Und habe es halt so gemacht, dass ich in meine Kategorien, also Bankbuchungen kommen rein, hast du da so ein Ding und dann willst du sagen, was ist das? Das ist einmal ein, was weiß ich, getankt oder... Taxi. Hotel, Taxi, genau. Und dann ist ja wichtig eben auch dann einerseits die richtige Steuerzuordnung zu machen, aber manchmal muss ja auch noch ein bisschen genauer werden, manchmal ist es dann irgendwie nicht so ganz genau. Und vor allem, und dann gibt es so einen Zielkonflikt in dieser ganzen Geschichte. Der Zielkonflikt war einerseits, wenn ich so ein Homebanking habe, also, Homebanking klingt auch bekloppt, Banking. Du hast quasi deinen ganzen Moneyflow vor der Nase und du möchtest jetzt irgendwie Dinge checken. Du wirst wissen, was passiert da. Wie viel Geld geht drauf für Tanken? Wie viel Geld gibst du aus in den Bürgerläden? Wie viel lässt du in deinem Supermarkt? Was geht für Kino drauf? Das sind so Dinge, die dich irgendwie manchmal interessieren. Das Finanzamt interessiert sich dafür für einen Scheißdreck. Für die ist nur wichtig, sind das 7% oder 19% Mehrwertsteuer? Oder ist das irgendwie so eine Abschreibung hier, lalalala? Also das, was dem Finanzamt wichtig ist, deckt sich überhaupt nicht mit dem, was für mich wichtig ist. Und am Anfang hab ich natürlich so, ah geil, Money, Money, Kategorien. Und dann hab ich halt alles erstmal so meine Kategorien mit was will ich wissen. Und dann später bin ich so in diesen Konflikt reingelaufen, dass das, was das Finanzamt wissen will, also die Kategorisierung, die ich dafür brauche und die Kategorisierung, die ich für mich brauche, überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun hat. Das ist natürlich sehr ärgerlich. Dann hab ich das halt so weiterentwickelt und mit den Bedürfnissen, diese Steuererklärung auch fertig zu bekommen, bin ich halt in zunehmendem Maße dahin gekommen, dass meine ganzen Kategorien vollkommen so nach Finanzamt ausgerichtet waren. Aber dann wirst du halt irgendwie auch bekloppt. Betriebskosten. Was ist das? Ja, genau. Werbekosten. Kannst du dir überhaupt gar nichts drunter vorstellen. Und jetzt hab ich das halt so gemacht, dass ich irgendwie diese ganzen Hierarchien der Kategorien benutze. Und wenn irgendwo in einer Kategorie Hierarchie in irgendeinem Punkt klar ist, was für eine Steuerbuchhaltungskontonummer da sozusagen verwendet werden muss, dann schreib ich die einfach mit in die Kategorie mit rein.
Verstößt das nicht gegen irgendeine Formel? Dass man nicht zwei Datenfelder in eins schreibende? So ein Datenbankgesetz?
Hier ist ja in dem Sinne gar keine Datenbank. Ich hab halt einfach eine Kategorie Hierarchie. Was weiß ich, ich nehm mal so ein Beispiel.
Du hast zwei Infos in einem Feld.
Also ich mach mal ein Beispiel. Da hab ich zum Beispiel hier eine Kategorie Gruppe, die heißt Versicherung oder genauer wäre in dem Fall private Versicherung. Und das ist wiederum unterteilt in Krankenversicherung und Rentenversicherung. Weil das will ich halt unterscheiden. Das Finanzamt unterscheidet das aber nicht. Sondern es ist in beiden Fällen halt Konto 2200. So, vorher hatte ich sozusagen nur die Kategorie, die 2200 ist und da musste dann da alles rein. Und es ist halt wieder alles zusammen gewurscht und das will man halt nicht. Und jetzt mach ich mir halt einfach so eine Kategorie Obergruppe, wo ich sage Versicherung, Privat. Alles, was jetzt hier drunter ist an Kategorien ist Konto 2200. Und dann kann ich da drunter halt Krankenversicherung, Rentenversicherung, Pipapo, was auch immer ich unterscheiden möchte, alles, was halt da reinpasst. Und ich kann aber auch was reinpassen, was vielleicht noch eine andere Konto-Nummer hat, weil wenn ich es dann nochmal ändere, in der Hierarchie da drunter überschreibt, ist quasi das, was es vorher vererbt hat. Das ist piffig! Und das Coole ist jetzt, jetzt bin ich auch vollkommen unabhängig von meiner Hierarchie und kann die ganze Zeit, während ich jetzt hier neue Buchungen reinkriege, denke ich mir so, ah nee, das müsste ich eigentlich ganz anders machen, kann die ganze Zeit meine Kategorie Hierarchien ändern, ohne dass hinten mir irgendeine bekloppte Konfigurationsdatei, die dann eben auf die volle Hierarchie-Match auseinanderfliegt. Und jetzt wird es richtig cool. Also ich sitze die ganze Zeit so da vorne und denke mir so, ach, gib mir nochmal 10 Buchungen, dann kann man nochmal ein bisschen was optimieren und jetzt passe ich sogar schon die Farben an und so.
Und lässt es drei Tage stehen damit wieder, wenn du das nächste Mal da bist, dass es auch wieder so eine ganze Schwungbuchung kommt, damit es auch richtig Spaß macht, ne? Und nicht nur so eine Einzelbuchung einmal am Tag da reinfliegt.
Nee, ich auch. Ich klick dann den ganzen Tag immer an die Kategorien durch und guck mal, was ich da noch verbessern kann. Ja, heute habe ich zum Beispiel die Kategorie Mietfahrzeuge eingeführt und die haben dann da drunter, wo ist es doch gleich? Mietfahrzeuge, wo seid ihr denn? Oh Gott, das sind schon so viele Kategorien geworden. Ah ja, hier Reisekosten, Mietfahrzeuge, genau.
66, 73.
Und dann habe ich halt eine Kategorie Car2go, eine Coup, eine EMI, eine Flinxster, eine Dreyfno. Immer mit den richtigen Farben wie auf der Webseite.
Ja, also müssen wir dir dann mal so dein Wim Richtung Lua pimpen.
Nee, Richtung CSV, da kann man eigentlich nicht.
Klammer zu, Klammer zu, Klammer zu.
Komm, wir zu was vollkommen anderem. Michaela, du hast neulich mit dieser 360 Grad-Geschichte rumgespielt und da würde mich jetzt mal dein Fazit interessieren.
Panono. Die Pleite sind. Sind sie?
Also da hat sie so ein Ding geliehen, das war irgendwie ganz beeindruckend.
Genau, das hieß Panono.
panono.com.
Auf Heise stand das. Ich google mal kurz. Linus hatte einen Heise-Link mit.
Also auf ihrer Webseite sind sie noch nicht.
Ja gut.
Pleite.
Und vielleicht auch nicht als erstes auf die Webseite. Panono ist Pleite vor vier Tagen. Google nach Heise und Panono. Ich bin nicht in diesem Chat.
Ja, ich bin schon dabei. Du bist nicht in diesem Slack. Warum eigentlich nicht?
Weiß nicht. Ich hab Slack erstmal zugelassen, wie ich es meistens mache.
Tja, Berliner Firma ist zahlungsunfähig. Guck an. Schade.
Jetzt weiß man auch, weshalb sie gesagt haben, das was ich gefixt haben will, noch in der Web-App. Wissen sie jetzt noch nicht genau, warum sie das umsetzen.
Gut, erzählen wir vielleicht mal erstmal, was das ist. Also Panono ist Hardware und Cloud in einem sozusagen. Und das ist so eine Tennisballgroße. Stimmt, oder ein bisschen größer? Mehr so Pampelmusen. Eher so Handball? Nee, Handball nicht.
Nee, Pampelmuse passt ganz gut.
Pampelmuse mit wie viel Augen?
32, 36?
Irgendwas in der Größenordnung.
36, eine Vollsphärenkamera mit 6, 32, 35.
Genau, und die haben mal angefangen mit dieser, diese Wuff, das erste Ding, was die gemacht haben.
Man hätte die auch mal hochwerfen sollen tatsächlich. Ich glaube, die löst dann oben aus an dem Punkt, wo, schätze ich mal.
Ach, die hat ja auch das Feature?
Ja, ich weiß, weil ich auch immer gesagt habe, nein, lass lieber nicht werfen, weil sie ist ja nur geliehen.
Stimmt, man muss sie ja auch auffangen.
Genau, und ich hätte sie nicht auffangen können. Aber es gab extra so Tutorials auch, wie man sie am besten wirft. Aus den Knien heraus.
Ja, damit sie gerade aufgleiten.
Dass sie gerade und sich nicht irgendwie noch ein paar Mal umdreht in der Luft. Ja, das hätten wir mal ausprobieren sollen, aber auch so war sie eigentlich ganz cool schon.
Genau, wir haben da nämlich, jetzt kann man das ja sagen, wir haben das Messegelände in Leipzig mal uns ein wenig dokumentiert, weil das ja Kandidat war für Kongress. Wie ihr ja nun mittlerweile alle wissen dürftet, geht der Kongress ja nach Leipzig. Und ich muss sagen, ich war ziemlich angetan, eigentlich von den Ergebnissen. Ich fand, dass das machte richtig Sinn. Also und zwar mehr Sinn als so normale Fotos. Also man konnte sich irgendwie 10-, 20-mal besser vorstellen, wie es da ist, als jetzt mit gut geschossenen Fotos.
Und jetzt stell dir vor, wir hatten eine Kamera, die zwei Augen immer hat und nochmal dreimal, also voll Sphäre. Und dann würdest du es noch in 3D tatsächlich sehen. Dann wärst du so richtig.
Das stimmt allerdings. Warum hatten wir das nicht?
Weil die Kameras, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das wirklich gibt. Du brauchst halt doppelt so viele Augen, weil du ja immer aus einer Augenposition zwei Fotos schießen musst und dann in alle Richtungen.
Ja, na gut, du brauchst zwei nebeneinander, die sich umeinander, die dann sozusagen auch nochmal gedreht werden auf so einem...
Minimum vier sozusagen. Minimum vier.
Vier Augen oder was? Nö, wozu?
Diese kleine Kamera, die ich habe, hat ja zwei Fischaugen. Damit geht es ja auch schon, dass du so eine volle Sphäre hast. Und eigentlich könnte man dann zwei von diesen Fischaugen nehmen, schätze ich mal, dann hast du zwei Augen und kriegst eine volle Sphäre aus zwei Augen-Positionen heraus.
Und du meinst, weil die dann so nebeneinander sind... Aber so ein bisschen Überlappung ist auf jeden Fall da. Nein, nein, nicht Überlappung, dass sie dasselbe sehen, sondern dass sie nicht aneinander vorbeisehen können. Also wenn du sie nicht drehst, du musst ja sozusagen auch das Drehen des Kopfes quasi da mit berücksichtigen, weil ja, wenn die nebeneinander sind, kann ja nicht jeder in jede Richtung gucken.
Genau, deswegen kriege ich vier vorne und hinten.
Wie auch immer, könnte man auf jeden Fall lösen und stimme dir voll zu, da würde dann VR voll Sinn machen. Aber nicht als User-Interface, sondern nur als Rohdatum.
Ja, dann willst du halt vielleicht da drin was machen und vielleicht irgendwelche Schilder mal austesten oder irgendwelche Abhängungen von der Decke mal testen oder solche Dinge und dann brauchst du schon wieder irgendein Interface, wo du den Kram halt herholst.
Ah, man kann sozusagen einen kompletten Kongress aufbauen im VR.
Kann man einmal kurz durchlaufen gucken. Ja, weiß ich nicht in dem Fall. Aber ja, Beschilderung testen könnte zum Beispiel ein Anwendungsfall sein. Bevor man es in groß macht, macht man es lieber mal digital.
Da würde ich sogar mitgehen. Aber bleiben wir vielleicht nochmal bei dieser Kugel. Ich meine, das ist jetzt ein bisschen doof. Das wäre jetzt vielleicht was zu reden, was jetzt schon wieder Pleite ist.
Hätten wir da mal 5 Wochen früher drüber geredet, hätten sich so viele Hörer das gekauft, dass die Firma das jetzt wunderbar hätte.
Aber wir hätten das auch gar nicht so empfehlen wollen, wegen dieser Web-App.
Naja, da war jetzt auch nicht alles Gold, was glänzt. Das Ding war an sich schon mal ganz gut. Ich fand die Ergebnisse jetzt ganz okay. Dieses Hochwerfen haben wir in dem Sinne gar nicht ausprobiert. Mir war das gar nicht bewusst, dass das das Produkt war, was das gemacht hat. Es machte einfach sehr viel mehr Sinn mit hochauflösenden Rundum-Fotos. Das ist wirklich cool.
Der Akku war nicht so gut.
Der Akku hat nicht so mega lange gehalten. War auch immer so ein bisschen unklar. Vom Manufakturing her, von der Reliability her, von der Zuverlässigkeit her war das alles ein bisschen im verbesserungswürdigen Bereich. Aber ist denn das die einzigen? Es gibt noch andere Vergleichbare, oder?
Mit so vielen Augen? Ich hatte mir ja erst überlegt, ich hab das ja für einen Auftrag geholt, wo ich hochauflösende Bilder wollte, die meine kleine Kamera nicht hergegeben hat. Und da hatte ich mir zuerst überlegt, ob ich für GoPro selbst, gibt es auch von anderen Herstellern, aber von GoPro selbst gibt es auch so einen Rig, wo man dann sechs GoPros einspannt. Da hatte mir allerdings der Verleiher in dem Berliner Action-Cam-Verleih in Spandau mir dann empfohlen, dass ich doch, wenn ich keine Videos machen will, sondern nur Fotos tatsächlich diese Panono nehmen soll, weil die eben irgendwie in dieser Preisklasse auch, was sind das irgendwie, so 2000 Euro waren das, die die kostet, glaube ich, wenn man sie neu kauft?
Was, die Panono?
Echt? Ja, die, genau, dass die doch besser wäre, wenn man keine Videos haben will, sondern sowieso nur.
Ah, 2150 heißt es hier.
Genau, und das GoPro Rig würde ich wahrscheinlich nehmen, wenn ich jetzt nochmal was mieten müsste für einen Auftrag und dann auch Videos haben will. Da war nur der Punkt, da meinte der Verkäufer dann auch, da brauchst du auch noch eine Software für, weil das muss ja immer irgendwie zusammengestitcht werden. Also diese ganzen Kameras machen irgendwelche Bilder und im Endeffekt muss irgendeine Software wissen, wie wird das jetzt zusammengestitched. Und wenn da, das weiß man halt auch vorher nie, wenn da der Algorithmus irgendwie scheiße ist, dann franzt das an den Nahtstellen aus. Und der hatte mich halt gewarnt vor dieser GoPro-Software und meinte, die kostet nochmal ein paar hundert Euro und dann wäre sie auch nicht so gut.
Ich habe auch schon mal so einen Rig in der Hand gehabt und das ist halt auch sehr sperrig alles. Also so viele Kameras, da hast du das Problem, du musst dann irgendwie auch alle laden, da sind tausend Kabel dran und Pipapo. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie sich das verbessert hat, aber du hast es dann halt mit dem Wust zu tun. Da müssen ja irgendwie auch alle extrem gut synchronisiert werden. Und ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, die Zukunft gehört wirklich den Kameras, die halt wirklich diesen 360 Grad komplett mit integriert haben. Da hat GoPro jetzt auch was?
Das ist das Rig von GoPro, das heißt Omni.
Achso, aber das sind vier?
Das sind sechs.
Sechs Kameras. Achso, okay, das ist aber von GoPro selber sozusagen.
Wenn ich richtig verstanden habe, braucht man aber, um das zu stitchen, nochmal irgendwie ein paar Hundert Euro Tor Software. Das kann aber sein, dass Demi das auch falsch erklärt hat. Genau, wenn ich jetzt was für Videos machen wollte und eben nicht eine ganz geringe Qualität nur haben will, wie diese paar Hundert Euro Kamera sie hat, dann würde ich vielleicht das GoPro Ding mal ausprobieren. Aber da werden auch irgendwie auch wöchentlich...
Aber das ist auch explizit für Video.
Das GoPro ist ja generell eher für Video als für Fotos.
Da muss man ja auch konzeptionell unterscheiden. Also diese Panono hat ja...
Die hatte kein Video.
Die hatte kein Video, genau.
Exizit für Fotos und die GoPro kann eigentlich beides, ist aber eher für Videos. Ich denke, es gibt aber auch noch Modelle im 5-stelligen Bereich. Ganz bestimmt. Und wie gesagt, da kommen auch immer... Das verfolge ich ja auch so ein bisschen, auch wegen dem anderen Newsletter, was da so an Kameras und Videos rauskommt.
Was heißt dem anderen Newsletter?
Machst du noch einen? Hab ich vorhin dir gesagt. Aber macht nichts.
Und? Willst du den auch fragen?
Da geht es um was?
Genau. Und da ist es ja auch eigentlich interessant, wo kommen die Assets her. Und deswegen schaue ich mir auch so ein bisschen an. Oder in meinem, wenn ich da so durchgehe, meine Google Alerts, kriege ich auch immer mit, wenn neue Kameras kommen. Und da kommen auch immer neue Modelle, ich glaube.
Sag doch nochmal die URL von deinem zweiten Newsletter.
Ja, die URL kenne ich nicht. Ich muss wieder den Bitly-Link aufrufen. Ja, das mögen ja manche nicht. WebVR-Comet.
Das ist ja einfach.
Ich müsste auch mal, das sind immer noch die Mailchimp-Rending-Pages, ich wollte da auch mal schöne Seiten machen. Das ist nichts geschehen bisher.
Zurück zu den Kameras. Also mit Videos natürlich, ich hab da auch mal eine Weile mit, nicht nur geliebäugelt, ich hab auch mal ein paar Experimente gemacht und da wird einem ja schnell klar, also bei den Fotos, das war ja der große Schwachsinn, wenn wir wieder in der Halle immer rumgerannt sind und dann immer so vor dem Auslösen, was man dann über die App macht, muss man sich immer verstecken.
Ganz oft sieht man uns so irgendwie.
Genau, so halb hinter unserem Baum verklemmt, aber man will ja immer raus aus dem Bild, damit du wirklich schon so eine nackte, befreite Optik hast. Bei Videos ist das natürlich herzlich kompliziert, weil du ja permanent Bilder erzeugst und du musst ja das Ding irgendwie führen. Also irgendwo drauf muss es halt irgendwie stehen. Und ist halt auch die Frage, was macht eigentlich auch Sinn? Dazu kommt, dass bei Foto macht es wirklich Sinn, so ein komplettes Vier zu haben, also wirklich eine vollständige Kugel abzubilden, weil du ja dann sowohl in Ruhe nach unten und nach oben gucken kannst. Bei Video wiederum ist es extrem knifflig, überhaupt zu entscheiden, wo guckst du eigentlich hin und wo macht es überhaupt Sinn, auch noch mitzufilmen? Weil das hängt natürlich davon ab, wie du das konsumierst. Also es muss ja jetzt nicht unbedingt immer diese Brille sein, mit der du überall hinschaust. Das kann ja auch sein, dass du das Ganze zum Beispiel in so einem Dom projizieren willst. Dass es sozusagen nur um das vorne-hinten geht. Und dann musst du natürlich auch überlegen, wie sitzt man da drin? Also steht man da frei und kann jederzeit überall hingucken? Oder ist das irgendwie mehr so eine Stuhlreingeschichte, wo es so einen Primärspot gibt, wo du hinguckst? Und dann musst du ja auch noch überlegen, dass das Video ja quasi gar nicht so einfach nur gerade nach vorne gucken kann, weil du ja dann unten irgendwo so einen Horizont hast, an dem du das abschneidest. Und wenn du jetzt so sitzt und so leicht nach oben guckst, musst du ja ein bisschen nach oben gucken, weil sonst müssten die Beamer durch deine Köpfe durch und so weiter. Das ist alles ein bisschen knifflig mit der Projektion, das heißt, die Projektion kommt von außen hinter einem Dom. Also wenn du jetzt einen Dom hast, musst du ja das Bild irgendwie da auch hinkriegen, sozusagen. Du musst ja irgendwie es schaffen, das Bild zu projizieren, ohne dass die Leute, die da drin sind, ein Problem sind. Also je nachdem, wie tief der gezogen ist, etc., musst du dann sozusagen auch entscheiden, worauf fokussiert sich das Video. Weil es ja in der Regel nicht unbedingt alles interessant ist. Du gehst einen Waldweg entlang. Dann schaust du zweimal nach links und nach rechts, weil ist ja der Wald so. Aber eigentlich folgst du mehr der Bewegung. Und die erwartest du halt vorne. Also du hast halt schon immer so dieses... Du hast ja auch in deiner Betrachtung der Welt immer einen vorne. Und ich glaube, dass man auch beim 360° Video irgendwie immer einen vorne drin haben muss. Und dann ist wahrscheinlich deine Perspektive auch eher so leicht nach unten getiltet. Weil du willst von dem, was vorne ist, mehr sehen. Auch unten und so. Aber hinten ist in dem Moment nicht ganz so interessant.
Ja, das sind auch so... Das sind diese Winkel auch, die interessant sind. Die sind ja auch... Die muss... Habe ich auch in den Talks erwähnt, weil es ist genauso wie du sagst, also nach vorne ist so ein bestimmter Winkel und nach oben, nach unten ein bisschen mehr sogar, weil man eher nach unten guckt, als den Nacken...
So bist du so Motorradhelm...
Genau, und eben zur Seite auch und alles andere, wo man sich total krass umdrehen muss hinter einem, da sollte vielleicht nicht so viel passieren beim Video oder bei User Interfaces auch.
Aber ich meine, diese Panono-Software, die hat ja so eine eigene Cloud, da muss man irgendwie die Bilder hochladen und dann wurde dieses Stitching gemacht, aber das hatten halt mehr oder weniger automatisch, oder? War das so, oder?
Die haben das dann online auf ihrem Server gestitched und dann konnte man die Bilder einzeln wieder herunterladen.
Ja, das war das.
Du musst auf jedes einzelne Bild erstmal draufklicken, um dann die Subseite mit dem Bild anzuzeigen und dort konnte man es dann herunterladen.
Weil sie ja davon ausgegangen sind, dass du in der Regel sowieso das Ganze in der fertigen Webseite mit User Interfaces und so weiter sehen möchtest, wo du so drin rumzoomst.
Find ich das Modell halt zu teuer für, wenn das jetzt nicht für Profis gemacht ist, sondern nur für einen, der mal im Schwimmbad steht.
Ja, genau, das ist so ein Punkt. Dann nimmst du dir halt auch potenzielle Autarkie und gerade was ist, wenn das jetzt sozusagen geheimes Material ist und darf das da rumstehen und zugriffen und all diese ganzen Kram. Das mag vielleicht eine kleine Fehleinschätzung gewesen sein, weiß nicht, das Business-Modell habe ich mir von denen nicht so ganz genau angeschaut und man weiß ja auch nicht unbedingt, wo es gehakt hat, aber am Ende haben sie ihre Cloud-Kosten sie in die Knie gezwenkt, weiß ich auch nicht. So oder so ein eigentlich schönes Produkt, was man, wenn ich genau in dieser Form dann zumindest in ähnlicher Form haben will. Es kommen so einige 360°-Kameras auf den Markt, aber was ich hier halt total überzeugend fahre, war durch diese Vielzahl an Kameras, war einfach die Auflösung wirklich so ratig groß. Was fandest du am Ende? 10.000? Mal irgendwas, also wirklich so fucking große Bilder, sodass du halt gerade so große Hallen, große Spaces einfach dich dann halt auch brauchbar reinzoomen konntest und einfach Details gesehen hast. Dadurch wirkt es überhaupt erst so echt, dadurch wirkt es überhaupt eigentlich auch sehr gut. Und ich meine, wenn man jetzt so eine Brille auf hat, dann...
15384 auf 8192.
Ja, das ist doch mal ein Statement.
32 MB, hier so ein dunkles Bild.
Krass, krass.
So muss es sein.
Ja, ja genau.
Und diese günstigen Kameras, die haben halt jetzt so zwei Augen und dann, was weiß ich, ist vielleicht so ein 4K-Sensor, ein Foto vielleicht ein bisschen höher. Die machen jetzt auch teilweise Video. Was ist jetzt so pixelmäßig gerade so en vogue bei Kameras?
Also die Megapixel, die steigen jetzt nicht mehr so krass wie noch so in den Anfängen, wo es sich jedes Jahr verdoppelt und verdreifacht hat. Also 24 bis 32 ist schon immer noch, glaube ich, gang gebe.
Na gut, dann ist halt die Frage, wie viel kombinierst du davon? Wie viele Überlappungen hast du da? Weil du für das ganze Stitching brauchst ja auch einfach eine hohe Auflösung, damit du das auch gut matchen kannst.
Ja, und du hast ja auch an den Seiten, du hast ja konzentriert vorne recht viel Auflösung und an den Seiten weniger, weil du es da aufstretchst. Ich glaube sogar, die Panono macht zum Schluss nicht nur das 4 draus, sondern online machen die, ach nee, der Service, mit dem wir das gemacht haben, dieses Marzipano-Tool, das hat zum Schluss gar keines Vier draus gemacht, sondern so ein Cube. Und es kann auch sein, dass die Cubes irgendwie weniger Verzerrung haben, weil die es eben nur in den Ecken vom Cube haben.
Ist was ein Open Source Tool oder was?
Es war ein Open Source Tool, was einer empfohlen hatte. Ich sage es jetzt nochmal dazu, dass ich mir das nicht ausgesucht habe, sondern jemand anderes. Genau. Damit haben wir die Tour dann zusammengeklickt. Marzipano. Ja, das.
Marzipano net, das nicht alles gibt.
Damit haben wir dann die Tour zusammengeklickt, weil die so ein Online-Tool hatten, wo man die Bilder einfach hochladen musste, und dann konnte man diese Waypoints, welches Panorama jetzt zu welchem führen sollte, also sagen wir mal, Leipzig-Messe-Eingang führt dann zu Leipzig-Messe-Eingangshalle und so weiter. Genau, damit haben wir das zusammengeklickt, und die machen glaube ich wirklich Cubes dann am Endeffekt draus, sobald ich das gesehen habe, und gar nicht mehr eine Kugel.
Tja, kamst bei Apple schon vor 20 Jahren.
Ja, ich meine, es gab ja im Internet-Explo, da gab es doch auch Würmel. Ja, wo Leute auch total aus dem Höschen gegangen sind für ihre Business-Modelle und was sie nicht alles.
Oh ja, das war diese zweite VR-Welle, da war alles in Swap, und jetzt Swap und 3D und Cyberspace und dann wieder nix. Und ich glaube, derzeit sind wir irgendwie bei dieser dritten Welle. Also wahrscheinlich entspricht auch dieser ganze VR-Kram, dieser Gardener Hype Curve perfekt.
Wir sind schon im...
Wir sind irgendwie manchmal immer noch so im Tal der... Wie ist es? Irgendwie sowas.
Uncanny Valley.
Was ist denn hier die Hype Curve? Na, ist auch wieder einer falschen Wikipedia.
1300 Pixel hat die kleine Kamerate.
Hype Cycle heißt es.
Slope of Enlightenment.
Genau, die Gardener Hype Curve. Technology Trigger kommt, dann kommt Peak of Inflated Expectations. Und dann der Throw of Disillusionment. Wir haben sie jetzt auf Deutsch übersetzt. Das waren auch ganz schöne Übersetzungen. Genau, Gipfel der überzogenen Erwartungen, Tal der Enttäuschungen. Und dann kommt man auf den Pfad der Erleuchtung. Und dann kommt das Plateau der Produktivität. Und vielleicht, wenn es gut läuft, sind wir irgendwie auf dem Pfad der Erleuchtung langsam eingebogen. Aber das Plateau der Produktivität ist noch weit entfernt auf jeden Fall.
Aber das sagen auch so die meisten Leute. Also letztes Jahr, als ich recherchiert habe, dass es eben da eben wieder im Hochgehen ist. Also wir befinden uns auf jeden Fall nicht irgendwie auf dieser ersten Hofkurve, sondern auf der zweiten.
Ja, ich hab bloß bei VR das Gefühl nicht los, dass es immer wieder neue technologische Auslöser gibt. Aber irgendwie kommt man über das Tal der Enttäuschung nicht weg. Vielleicht das erste System, was diese Kurve so ein bisschen...
Ich kann mich auf jeden Fall noch erinnern, ich hoffe, ich trete jetzt keinem zu nahe, aber ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass mir jemand mal so sagte, ihr hättet jetzt so ein Business-Modell, und zwar, ich glaube, es war sogar eine UDK, wo es darum ging, Ausstellungen in Würmel, also im Web, in Virtual Reality zu machen, statt in der Galerie. Und dass er sozusagen einen virtuellen Galeriespace, also dann jetzt sozusagen an den Mann bringen und die Frau bringen wollte. Und dann, okay, habe ich mir das alles so angehört, und dann zeigte er mir das, wie das gerade so aussieht. Und dann ruckelte da so eine grobe Polygonlandschaft vor einem da nieder. Also da war ich auf jeden Fall ganz unter dem Tal enttäuscht.
Oh, war das schlecht.
Na ja, aus dem Projekt ist nichts geworden. Kann man auf jeden Fall noch abschließender zu sagen.
Ja, Google hat auch so eine Galerie als Example-App. Wenn bei diesem Daydream Zeug dabei, sitzt man dann auch irgendwie in so einem Galerie-Raum, und von hinten scheint die Sonne rein, und vorne sind so Fotos.
Naja, irgendwann kannst du vielleicht durchs MoMA gehen, ohne da sein zu müssen. Ist das dann nicht gleich?
Kannst du jetzt in Google Street View schon durchs Computer-History-Museum durchgehen? Macht man das?
Kommt Kinder, wir stellen uns aufs Laufband und gehen mal durchs Museum.
Gehen wir doch eine Runde übern Blog, oder schauen wir nur bei Google Street View, wie der Park aussieht?
Ja, also vielleicht ist das dann, wenn dann die Kamera dazu kommt, ist das dann irgendwie geiler. Und dann noch ein Podcast dazu, der irgendwie schön synchronisiert ist. Weißt du, das ist dann so, von einem Podcast durch das Museum führen lässt. Und dann so das 3D-Bild dann so mit wandert. Na ja, das ist ja eh so eine Überlegung, die ich schon häufiger mal...
Klingt jetzt den Kaufen-Button auf Meta.me schrägstrich VR?
Das ist eine, der schon... eine Idee, die unter Garantie irgendwann umgesetzt werden wird. Die Frage ist nur, von wem und von wem erfolgreich und zuerst. Aber es ist eigentlich schade, dass man einen Podcast nicht auch mit einem GPS-Trail versehen kann. Also parallel zu dem Audio, ich meine, das wäre jetzt im Falle der Freak Show relativ langweilig, weil wir sind ja sozusagen nur hier im Studio, ja. Aber das wäre ja dann quasi eine Motivation, Metadaten so anzureichern, dass du sagst, okay, ich gehe zum Beispiel durch eine Stadt durch.
Aber das gab es doch schon. Und zwar zum, warte, vom Bayerischen Rumpf, Rumpf, Rumpf, Rumpf, Rumpf. Ich glaube, das war eine andere Geschichte.
Es gibt da verschiedene Projekte, es gibt da auch so Audiomaps und Tours und Tralala und irgendwelche geografischen Verortungen, aber wovon ich halt konkret spreche ist, dass du quasi mit dem Audiotrack auch noch so einen Movement-Track hast. Wirklich so eine Map macht, wo Rantastic für Podcasts schön gesagt.
Du musst dann zur nächsten Ecke laufen, damit das nächste Thema kommt.
Rantastic für Podcasts wäre dann wiederum andersrum ganz interessant, wenn sozusagen jetzt alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die diesen Podcast gerade beim Laufen hören mit Rantastic, quasi dann synchronisiert mit der Sendung ihren GPS-Trail einsenden und man dann wiederum so eine Map bekommt, wo alle gerade langlaufen, während, wo warst du, als die Letti sagten, hören...
Ich fall gleich vorm Stuhl.
Und dann blitzen die ganzen Orte auf und wenn man dann diese Karte vor sich sieht, dann kann man da geheime satanische Botschaften draus ablesen.
Träume werden wahr.
Okay, springen wir zum Thema.
Jetzt müsst ihr mir das mal mit dem Stricken mal erklären. Also ich kann ja stricken.
Theoretisch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du mich da jetzt wirklich ranlassen willst. Du kannst wieder aufziehen. Nur die rechte Masche. Oh Gott, ich hab schon so lange nicht mehr gestrickt. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das noch kann.
Das vernenkt man nicht, wie Fahrradfahren, Tim.
Ich muss jetzt wirklich mal überlegen, wann hab ich das letzte Mal gestrickt in meinem Leben?
Die nachfolgenden Zündungen.
Ich hab das in der Schule gelernt. Und ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass nach der Schule groß zur Anwendung gebracht zu haben. Du meinst, das verlernt man nicht? Ich nehm die andere Nadel.
Die, die da freilegt, die kannst du nehmen, um den...
Um was zu machen?
Um das nächste Stück zu stricken.
Also strickt man nicht mit den beiden, die hier schon sind?
Weil du dann eine verloren hast und dann haben wir nur noch drei. Und wenn du so weitermachst, sind ja dann gar keine mehr da.
Also ich muss sagen, so Strick-Operationen, wo so vier Nadeln drinstecken, das kenne ich nicht mehr aus der Schule.
Aber du kannst jetzt diese Nadel, die aktive, mit der abstrecken und dann ersetzt du die halt.
So, für den Hörer, der das jetzt gerade nicht hört, Tim versucht zu verstehen, wie man Socken steht.
Mit einem Nadelspiel.
Mit einem Nadelspiel, bestehend aus vier Nadeln. Von Nitpro, die schönsten Nadelspieler, die es gibt.
Wirklich?
Die sind Tim, der rutscht die Wolle extra fluffig von der Nadel. Kannste nicht viel fassen.
Und Tim sitzt vor dieser Socke jetzt wie das Schwein vom Urwerk.
Ich hab jetzt so ein bisschen Angst, hier irgendwas zu zerstören. Irgendwie, aber ich meine, muss man nicht, ich kenn das nur so, dass ich die beiden Nadeln, wo die Maschen drauf sind...
Guck mal, das ist das, was ich habe. Das sind nur zwei Nadeln. Und du hast aber ein Nadelspiel. Das ist flach gestrickt, auch wenn man es gerade jetzt nicht sieht. Das ist ein flach gestricktes Stück.
Es hat zwei offene Enden sozusagen. Es ist nicht geschlossen.
Du weißt, dass die Hörer das nicht hören, wenn du das so hoch hältst. Du musst schon genauer beschreiben, was da ist.
Also wir sehen, jeder weiß, wie ein Schal aussieht, wenn der Schal kein Loop ist, sondern ein ganz normaler Schal oder ein Tuch rechtecklang. Und was das heißt, wenn man sagt, man strickt flach, ist, dass man eben keinen geschlossenen Kreislauf in seinem Strickgut hat, sondern keine Röhre. Genau. Und dann hat man nur zwei Nadeln. Wenn man aber wieder timm versucht, mit der Socke klarzukommen, hat man ein Nadelspiel und um in der Runde zu stricken, brauchst du, um einen Kreis zu bilden, mindestens drei bis vier Nadeln. Je nach Größe vielleicht sogar fünf. Und die Größe der Socke, die Dicke der Wolle kommt natürlich auch noch hinzu. Und was man halt hat, während man aktiv versucht, eine Socke zu stricken, ist, man hat zwei Nadeln in der Hand, das eine ist mit einem führenden Faden.
Also ich merke gerade, ich erinnere mich nicht ausreichend. Mir ist es noch nicht mehr so geläufig.
Dann ersetzt du immer eine Nadel von den Vieren im Nadelspiel.
Und so kannst du dich quasi im Kreis vorwärts bewegen. Das ist wie so eine For-Each, Tim.
Aber Crotchet ist häkeln.
Ja, das außerdem.
Das wollte ich übrigens auch mal machen. Man kann ja so mini kleine Sachen häkeln, ne?
Ja, ich finde häkeln so...
Es sieht immer so hässlich aus, aber ich glaube, es macht Spaß zu erstellen.
Ich weiß nicht, ich finde häkeln irgendwie... Damit habe ich mich nie so richtig angefreundet, glaube ich. Ich habe ein paar Sachen gehäkelt, aber es sieht immer so oll aus. Im Vergleich, wenn man Stricken und Häkeln vergleicht, beim Stricken kann man ganz, ganz weich stricken. Also dass die Klamotte dahinter auch wirklich weich ist und dein Kuschelpulli wirklich kuschelig ist. Und während du beim Häkeln natürlich manchmal das Problem hast, dass es viel zu fest wird, dann ist es eher...
Erst klatschen, wenn es stimmt. War die richtig? Oder habe ich es falsch gemacht? Was heißt Glück gehabt? Ich muss dir jetzt gerade mal was aus meinem Hirn abrufen, was da vermutlich nach 40 Jahren so vor sich hin geschlummert ist.
War noch im Muskelgedächtnis.
Offensichtlich. Ich kann mich noch liebhaft an meinen Handarbeitunterricht erinnern. Da hab ich so einiges getan.
Hab ich nie Stricken gelernt.
Ich bin jetzt wirklich Textil nicht besonders bewandert. Aber ich weiß zumindest, wie man näht. Und mit dem Stricken hab ich jetzt vielleicht auch nicht ganz so. Mit einer Nähmaschine kommt mich sogar klar.
Ich hab ein interessantes Gespräch vor anderthalb Wochen in einem Workshop von meinem aktuellen Projekt gehabt mit einer weiteren ITlerin, mit der ich darüber sprach. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie wir aus Stricken gekommen sind. Und ich hab zu ihr gesagt, naja, Stricken ist für mich wie Programmieren. Und dann guckte sie erst so und war so ein bisschen skeptisch. Und dann überlegte sie so und meinte, ja, du hast eigentlich recht. Du hast Iterationen eigentlich nur, du hast Muster, die sich wiederholen. Und du kannst einen Schal in irgendwie Pseudocode schreiben.
Also ist es eigentlich weniger Programmieren als mehr Programme ausführen?
Programme ausführen, ja, aber du überlegst ja vorher eigentlich den Algorithmus dazu. Also du kommst ja nicht oft, also ich hab jetzt hier ein ausgedrucktes Zettel, weil sich jemand anderes mal darüber Gedanken gemacht hat, was er gern für einen Schal hätte. Wenn du natürlich aber keine Idee hast, dann machst du dir selber die Gedanken. Und dann kannst du schon sagen, ok, das was du dann da runterschreibst an Informationen zum Stricken, ist nichts anderes als Pseudocode. Weil du sagst halt auch so, ok, ich will einen Schal, der hat die und die Dimension. Und da soll ein Muster drin vorkommen. Und das Muster soll 20 cm breit sein und 30 cm lang. Dann machst du dir darüber Gedanken, wie du stricken musst, damit du dieses Muster bekommst. Das ist eigentlich nichts anderes, als sich über deinen Algorithmus beim Coden Gedanken zu machen.
Gerade auch so bei Ab- und Zunahmen?
Genau, gerade bei Ab- und Zunahmen. Also wenn du dein Strickstück halt......bitzulaufen lassen willst. Ja, oder beim Pullover, wenn du deine Talie ausformen willst und nicht nur ein gerade nach unten gehende Linie haben willst. Dann arbeitest du mit Abnahmen und dann auch wieder mit Zunahmen. Das musst du dir vorher natürlich überlegen, wie groß bist du, wie lang bist du, wie weit musst du stricken und wie weit musst du ab und zu nehmen drum.
Schleifenvariablen.
Das ist die Frage, ob du bei Null oder bei Eins anfängst.
Ja, beim Stricken fängt man mit der Reihe Eins an. Wobei es nicht stimmt eigentlich nicht. Reihe Null ist ja der Anschlag vielleicht. Okay, wir haben Reihe Null.
Zum Schluss weiß ich auch nie, wie ich zählen soll.
Das meiste sagt dir dein Strickmuster, weil es steht da, cast on, so und so viele Stitches. Und dann beginnt es mit Row One. Also Reihe Null ist in der Tat der Cast-on. Also das Anschlagen der Maschen.
Der Chat hat schon wieder ein paar interessante Häkeldinge. Hipster-Tipps hier.
Ja, das ist aber alles gehäkelt.
Das hier ist gehäkelt?
Ja, Crushed ist Stricken, äh Häkeln.
Das Häkelschwein ist auch gehäkelt.
Das Häkelschwein ist auch gehäkelt. Das stimmt, das sagt schon der Name.
Das Häkelschwein ist super.
Eine Freundin aus München, die ist auch so ganz große Häkel-Expertin, die hat cactusgarten.de, die häkelt Cactus und die sind total beliebt und verkauft die auf der Wanda und sonst wo. Und auf Facebook gibt es auch so eine Seite von ihr, wo sie unter Cactusgarten ihre ganzen anderen Kreationen hat. Und die ist da auch total im Häkel-Wahnsinn und macht so, hier zum Beispiel, war das hier Plants vs. Zombies, halt mal einmal so durchgehäkelt und lauter so Zeug.
Das verkauft sie.
Tim ist neuer Kunde.
Ich weiß nicht, warte mal, ich guck mal gerade.
Ich sehe glückliche Kinder.
Die haben doch auch so einen speziellen Namen.
Wo ist denn das Cactusgarten, wo, wie, was?
Also, ich glaube, sie verkauft sie gerade nicht mehr, weil sie gerade total im Laufwahnsinn ist. Und ihr Davander-Shop ist gerade leer.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man es ausspricht. Ja, genau. Das ist diese Art von Häkeln, wenn man kleine Tierchen...
Aber die war da eine Zeit lang einfach mega... Also ich glaube, hier verkauft sie, hatte sie nur ihre Kakteen verkauft. Und wenn du auf die Facebook-Seite gehst, die ist hier. Wenn du da ein bisschen runterscrollst, da gibt es dann halt so diverse...
Wie nennt man das nochmal?
Ja, das hat sie auf jeden Fall eine lange Zeit gemacht, aber ich glaube, sie ist jetzt so irgendwie im Laufsport angekommen und...
Will nicht mehr häkeln.
Ich kann sie mal anschreiben. Vielleicht macht sie für dich ja nochmal so eine Aktion.
Es ist halt auch sau anstrengend, das zu häkeln, weil du halt teilweise echt mit dünnem Garn arbeitest, kleiner Häkelnadel und das halt sehr, sehr kleine Objekte auch sind.
Ich kann sie gerne mal fragen, ob sie noch ein bisschen Häkelpassion jetzt übrig hat.
Hörst du sie oder was?
Ja, aber sie ist jetzt nicht auf diesen Bildern da gerade zu sehen, sondern ich weiß gar nicht, welche Leute das sind, irgendwelche Laufpartnerinnen oder so. Aber Chet will sehen, Chet muss auf Facebook klicken. Und ein bisschen runterscrollen. Ja, also, das ist auf jeden Fall auch, die hat da auch so einen totalen Hekelfilm gefahren, eine Zeit lang. Auch wirklich sehr putzige Sachen. Und dafür gibt es halt dann auch so nicht Strickmuster, sondern Hekelmuster. Und sie hat dann halt auch für ihre ganzen Sachen da diese Dinger dann verkauft in ihrem Shop, also auch die Hekelmuster, lauter so Auftragsarbeiten da gemacht. Also da Hekelschwein hat sie gemacht. Ja, natürlich, das muss doch auch sein.
Ja, ein bisschen anders noch als das Hekelschwein, aber immerhin auch ein gehöriges Schwein.
Genau, und ich habe auch von ihr einen so einen kleinen Hekelkaktus mit Keramikpop. Ja, die kannst du auf dieser kaktusgarten.com-Seite, da gibt es dann unter Produkte, die verschiedenen, die großen und die kleinen und die Ohrringe und da muss man hier bei Produkte, glaube ich, und dann genau die großen, genau die sehen dann so aus und die kleinen sind aber, finde ich, viel putziger. Genau, das gibt es als Ohrringe. Ja, also sie war da auf jeden Fall auch echt mit der Hekennadel unterwegs.
Okay, Stricken und Häkeln bringt mich übrigens auch zum interessanten Nachklapp. Eine unserer legendären Folgen war ja Vier Maschen pro Pixel mit Fabienne, die ja leider immer noch dauerhaft in den USA weilt, aber dort, wie ich auch schon mal zwischendurch irgendwann berichtet hatte, ja dieses Strickprojekt gestartet hat. Crowdfunding und dann hat sie sich diese fette deutsche Strickmaschine, jetzt hab ich den Hersteller schon wieder vergessen, geschoppt und geschippt sozusagen, irgendwie im Bötchen über den Atlantik geschippert, bis das dann irgendwie in Seattle ankam. Und dort hat sie das dann im Laufe des letzten Jahres zum Laufen gebracht und dann hat sich irgendwie da ein Wolf programmiert. Natürlich hat alles viel länger gedauert als gedacht. Ich weiß gar nicht, wann fing das an, Anfang letzten Jahres oder so. Und jetzt kommen wir sozusagen in die Produktion. Das heißt, nach langer, langer Zeit ist es ihr tatsächlich gelungen, nicht nur so theoretisch, algorithmisch zu arbeiten, sondern sie setzt halt jetzt mit der Strickmaschine wirklich algorithmisches Stricken um. Das heißt, sie entwickelt halt Code, der Muster erzeugt, die dann wiederum programmatisch von dieser Strickmaschine Zeile für Zeile in echtes Textil umgesetzt werden. Und da können wir mal kurz den Sound dieser Maschine anhören hier. Sehr viel sehen tut man da nicht, außer dass da unten so langsam Schritt für Schritt so ein Schal rauskommt. Wieso hören Sie nichts?
Warum hören Sie nichts?
Was soll ich hören?
Wie soll ich denn hier nichts?
Lieber Kopfhörer absetzen, gleich hat man wieder zu viel.
Ich wundere mich gerade, warum ich nichts höre. 25.
Mir ist noch ein Nachtrag, den ich weil anderen schon angebracht habe zu irgendeiner Sendung, wo du über diese Pussyheads gesprochen hast und das passt zu dem Strickthema noch ein bisschen, weil es natürlich auf eine der bekanntesten Community-Seiten für Stricken aufgekommen ist, dieser Pussyhead-Trend, wo eben zum Beispiel auch diese ganzen Strickmuster für die Häkelschweinchen auch verfügbar sind. Die heißt halt Reveille. Ich glaube, man sieht ohne eingeloggt zu sein, man sieht dann nichts, außer Alpakas, genau, das nennt er Artwork.
Reveille ist so eine abgeschlossene Community, die extrem viel in diesem Maker-Bereich hat, aber ich hab da einen Account.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, Tim, mhm.
Wer richtige Maschen strecken kann.
Ich gehe den Dingen ja dann auch stellenweise auf die Spur. Ja, da wird viel geklöppelt und gearbeitet und gestrickt und getan. Da gibt es ja auch nochmal so eine ganz eigene Podcast-Szene auch, die sich sozusagen in diesem Reverie abbildet, die extrem viel Maker-Kram umfasst.
Ja, aber leider gibt es den besten Strick-Podcast nicht mehr.
Was war denn der beste Strick-Podcast?
Für mich waren es die Nitterpunks, weil das halt eben so ein paar verrückte Mädels waren. Also wirklich Leute, die nicht, ich weiß nicht, despektierlich sagen, aber halt nur diesen Kinderkrempel stricken, sondern die halt auch versucht haben. Also die eine hat halt sich Stricken beigebracht und dabei Schnittmuster veröffentlicht, damit sie das lernen kann. Und daraus ist die dies halt echt in dieser Community ziemlich bekannt, aber die design jetzt glaube ich größtenteils Schals und Dreieckstücher. Die hat aber mal super abgefahrene Designs, die einfach auch schön sind. Und zum Beispiel, die kümmert sich halt auch um das komplette, also die hat so eine kleine Community um sich, so die eine macht das komplette technical, wie heißt das, Reviewing und also die sich so ein bisschen schon Richtung Type-O setzen, des Schnittmusters, oder Strickmusters, dass es halt nicht nur so ein komischer Textblock ist, der dich verrückt macht, wenn du damit arbeitest, sondern wirklich ein sehr gut designtes Textdokument einfach auch ist und auch zum Beispiel die ganzen Bilder, die Modelle, das macht sie halt alles selber, die Fotos und hat halt nicht nur so diese, diesen Standard-Typ an Mensch, den sie fotografiert, sondern auch sehr schöne bunte Menschen, die einfach total zutätowiert sind und also eine wirklich coole Designerin einfach auch ist. Ja und die halt zusammen mit einer anderen...
Wo soll man da mal gucken, bei Nitterpunks, aber gibt's doch hier noch die Webseite.
Nitterpunks gibt's glaube ich noch, gibt's die noch? Ja genau, die gibt's noch, aber die ist, ich glaub die sind... Ja, aber die waren halt schon relativ cool, weil ja sie halt eben auch nicht so diese Standardmenschen, die in dieser Community sind. Unterwegs waren ja genau Jocelyn und Sylvia. Ja das war cool, weil es halt auch so ein richtiger nerdigen Mädchen sind. Also es hat Spaß gemacht, denen zuzuhören, auch wenn sie jetzt sag ich mal nicht, also sie haben schon sehr viel Technisches auch mit abgedeckt. Aber das ist von Jocelyn und ihrem Mann.
Okay, da geht's um was ganz anderes.
Also den hab ich echt immer gern zugehört, weil es nicht so dieses, nicht so dieser Standard, den du halt in dieser Strickszene vorfindest, hast.
Ich hoffe ja, dass Fabienne irgendwann mal wieder hier vorbeischauen kann. Das wäre eigentlich ganz cool. Aber ich glaube, sie ist noch sehr damit beschäftigt, sehr noch damit beschäftigt ihren Produktionsprozess zu starten. Ich hoffe, dass das jetzt in den nächsten Monaten mal abgearbeitet ist. Vielleicht kriegen wir sie ja mal wieder zum Kongress nach Deutschland gelockt. Was kann man sich schöneres vorstellen, als aus einer warmen Westkurs schön in den deutschen Winter zu tauchen? Also es gibt nichts besseres. Also ich verstehe, das hat so etwas Kontemplatives, ne? Michaela ist auch vollkommen richtig. Strick, Strick, Strick. Das ist ja auch nichts anderes, als die ganze Zeit auf seinem Smartphone rumlesen und irgendwie Twitter-Timeline, ne? Oder so Candy Crush oder so was.
Aber man kann halt noch ein paar andere Sachen nebenbei machen.
Ja, aber vor allem man produziert ja dann auch irgendwas, was man sich dann nach und nach irgendwie anziehen kann. Das ist algorithmischer Zeitvertreib mit lang anerhaltenden Effekten.
Ich wollte auch irgendwann mal was lernen. Ich hab das gar nicht in der Schule gelernt, sondern erst so vor vielleicht fünf Jahren oder so, weil ich irgendwie was lernen wollte, was man benutzen kann, wenn überall der Strom ausfällt und so. Und alle hatten irgendwie einen geilen Skill, wie ich kann irgendwie mit Pflanzen umgehen oder ich kann kochen und so. Und ich bin nicht so direkt, was ich so kann. Und dann dachte ich, Anziehsachen machen aus einem Stück Faden, das ist so irgendwie geil.
Ja, vielleicht soll ich das auch mal machen. Ich bin so furchtbar unkreativ, was so Textilien betrifft. Das ist wirklich schlimm. Also ich krieg mich ja auch nicht mal motiviert, irgendwie mit einem neuen Satz Hosen zu kaufen, bevor nicht die letzte komplett auseinandergefallen ist. Ich weiß, das ist gar nicht dein Ding, ne?
Kauf und Sachen kaufen gehen, Klamotten kaufen gehen, mich in ein Ladengeschäft stecken, wo Menschen sind.
Wie viel Prozent der Klamotten, die du trägst, hast du selbst gemacht?
Ich hab meinen Gesamtbestand, würde ich fast sagen, sind fast 90 Prozent mittlerweile.
Das ist halt wirklich...
Ich hab da letztens erst mal nachgedacht und dachte mir so, wow, das fehlt nicht mehr viel, dass ich alles ersetze. Ich hab mir jetzt halt im Januar... Nee, das noch nicht. Und das ist das eigentlich was... Nee, ist es nicht. Also Sport-BHs, ja. Aber Unterwäsche an sich eigentlich nicht. Und das ist noch das, so das letzte, wo ich mir jedes Mal wieder denke, so boah, es war jetzt wirklich genau diese Situation. Ich stand im Laden, sollte Unterwäsche kaufen, dachte mir so, schwarz, möglichst schlicht, einfach. Ach so, meinen Wintermantel habe ich halt dieses Jahr jetzt endlich fertig genäht. Und den Wintermantel, den ich jetzt habe, der leider ein wenig warm ist wahrscheinlich für den Berliner Winter, ja, den habe ich halt jetzt fertig genäht. Und jetzt habe ich einen fetten Wintermantel, den ich auf einmal selber gemacht habe. Und da war ich so kurz so, schön, endlich mal dieses Monster-Projekt fertig bekommen.
Wie schwierig ist denn da so der Einstieg?
Ins nähen?
Ne, ins Kleidung machen.
Naja, nicht. Naja, also ich finde das Hauptproblem ist eigentlich, dass wenn man anfängt, man denkt, man kommt mit einer günstigen Maschine weit. Also Nähmaschine weit. Ich finde das größere Problem ist am Anfang bereit zu sein oder vielleicht sich irgendwo ausleihen zu können, eine gute Nähmaschine, weil dann bist du nicht so krass frustriert. Also zum Beispiel T-Shirt Stoff.
Also nicht wegen der Maschine zumindest.
Also was heißt denn gute Maschine?
Eine gute Maschine ist, dass du Jersey Stoffe, also dass Jersey Stoffe sind üblicherweise T-Shirt Stoffe, die elastisch sind. Die musst du gut nähen können, weil so ein T-Shirt zu nähen geht echt schnell. So rein von dem Nähen her. Und du kannst noch nicht so viel falsch machen, wenn es jetzt nicht so richtig 100 pro sitzt, weil es dehnt sich. Also im Zweifelsfall sind die zwei Zentimeter, die dir vielleicht um die Hüfte fehlen, ganz ausbügeln oder ausdehnen lassen. Nein, aber das ist dann halt nicht so schwer. Und wenn du eine Maschine hast, die aber diesen Stich nicht so richtig kann, also ein Stich muss dann halt miterlastig sein mit dem Stoff. Naja, die Nähmaschine kannst du ja programmieren, oder die Nähmaschine hat Programme definiert, programmiert. Ein Stich ist die, denn jeder kennt diesen ganz normalen, geraden Stich und der ist aber null elastisch. Wenn du aber die Maschine so konfigurierst, dass dein Stich sehr eng wird und fast wie ein Zickzack aussieht, also fast so ein Zickzackstich in ganz, ganz klein, kannst du den Stoff immer noch dehnen, weil du meistens auch so eine Vor- und Rückwärtsbewegung drin hast in der Nadel. Sodass dann halt die Elastizität nicht verloren geht. Und diesen Stich drin zu haben in der Maschine, erfordert halt eine gute Maschine. Also dass du halt wirklich sagen kannst, eine Nähmaschine unter 500 Euro ist Quatsch. Also da kann man halt nicht davon ausgehen, dass es eine qualitativ hochwertige Maschine ist. Also Neupreis. Natürlich kannst du halt auch gebraucht schauen, weil einige Hersteller...
Ja logisch, aber was würdest du so...
Für mich gibt es nur eine Marke. Und das ist Bernina. Das ist eine Schweizer Firma.
Bernina, ja.
Also das ist so das, was im Consumer-Bereich, sage ich mal, ich würde fast denken, dass es das Beste ist. Und die sind halt, also ich habe meine jetzt seit fast zehn Jahren. Und ich habe sie noch nicht einmal zur Wartung bringen müssen. Also die... Und die sind halt wartungsarm, also die halten sehr lange. Ja, das ist die Stricksoftware, die du siehst. Also Sticksoftware so rum. Ein Berliner hat normale Nähmaschinen und Stickmaschinen. Also Stickmaschinen sind das, womit du hier auf dem Kongress dir das Kongress-Logo draufsticken lässt. Und ich habe auch in der Tat eine Maschine, die man um ein Stickmodul erweitern könnte. Aber ich nutze das nicht, weil ich das nicht brauche. Und was du aber zum Beispiel bei diesen etwas hochpreisigeren Modellen von denen halt machen kannst, ist zu sagen, mit wie viel Druck dein Nähfuß auf deinen Stoff drückt. Das heißt, wenn du einen schweren Stoff hast, willst du vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Druck ausüben, damit der gut transportiert wird. Wenn du jetzt aber hier so einen fluffigen Kleiderstoff hast, der wirklich so ein Hauch ist, da willst du natürlich ganz, ganz vorsichtig rangehen. Und dann kannst du den Nähfuß halt so einstellen, dass der Stoff nicht irgendwie beschädigt wird oder so was. Und ja, wenn dir die Öl ist und du kommst halt auch wirklich an viele Sachen ran, kannst viele Sachen selber einstellen, wenn sich irgendwie die Fadenspannungen ändern. Und einige Hersteller versuchen das halt zu restriktieren, nach dem Motto, hier drehen wir nicht an dieser Schraube, dann geht die Garantie flöten. Tim sieht gerade die verschiedenen Arten von Nähfüßen und ist sich überfordert, weil es gibt extrem viele Nähfüße. Also Nähfüße sind das, was man an die Nähmaschine ran spannt sozusagen. Ja, um an die Nähmaschine ran zu spannen, wo die Nähnadel drin sitzt. Oder ist so ein bisschen die Führung der Nähnadel. Die Führung ist glaube ich nicht das Richtige. Aber auch, um den Stoff zu fixieren und zu transportieren. Das, was du mit dem Kabel da siehst, ist ein Kilting-Modul. Und da vermute ich, werden die noch irgendeine Info zusätzlich haben von der Nähmaschine.
Alter Schwede, das ist ja mal wieder so ein Technologiebereich, wo ich irgendwie endlich auch nur den Hauch einer Ahnung hatte.
Nee, es gibt da halt auch wirklich sehr viele Sachen. Also du musst natürlich davon ausgehen, es ist wie bei so einem MacBook. Da brauchst du jetzt auch nicht unbedingt immer das rechts unten Modell mit allem Schnickschnack. Nein, Entschuldigung, mein Fehler. Ein 2016er MacBook. Oh, das ist 2016 ausgekommen, der Schrott.
Okay, aber was sind denn jetzt hier sozusagen die angesagten Nähmaschen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es die angesagten sind, aber für Nähmaschinen finde ich die super und ich werde mir...
Zweier, Dreier, Vierer, Fünfer, Siebener, Achter-Serie?
Ich habe eine Vierer-Serie, die ist nicht mehr verfügbar. Und als ich die mir gekauft habe, war so der erste Moment, oh fuck, mein MacBook war günstiger als meine Nähmaschine.
Und was hat die gekostet?
1,5 damals. Das habe ich von meinem ersten Gehalt relativ stolz gekauft. Und das war, also ich habe die seit...
Sag mal ein Modell, was man hier mal so anklicken kann.
Wahrscheinlich eine Fünfer-Serie oder eine Dreier-Serie.
Fünfer.
Nimm mal die 530er einfach ganz unten.
Einstiegsmodell.
Das ist kein Einstiegsmodell, das ist schon...
Für die Fünfer-Serie.
Oh wow, die sind teurer geworden.
2000 Zacken.
Ja, also Benina hat halt auch Einstiegsmodelle.
Die sieht aber geil aus.
Ja, ich weiß.
Es gibt sogar eine schwarze Nähmaschine von denen.
Später immer dann der Feminin, also das sind dann nur für Näherinnen in dem Fall.
Ich glaub ja, steht überall nur.
Für ambitionierte Näherinnen.
Na toll, ich fühle mich ausgeschlossen.
Das war's.
Das war's. Gibt's hier auch was für Männer? Für Männer gibt's bestimmt so eine One-Button-Maschine mit irgendwie Knopf.
Der Nähautomat.
Saum.
Oh krass, also ich seh grad, dass Bernina die Preise ordentlich angezogen hat und es gab mal eine Maschine, ich würde fast meinen, die war so im Dreh von 500 Euro. Die, eine ganz einfache Nähmaschine, war aber eine sehr solide. Aber die scheint es auch schon nicht mehr zu geben.
Was ist denn Quilt hin, bitte?
Diese Decken, das ist so typischerweise, was man früher mit Hand hat, Decken zu steppen. Steppdecken mit so Motiven drauf, meistens geschachtelt aus mehreren Mustern. Ist im Übrigen auch ein algorithmisches Problem, wie man die Muster anordnet. Üblicherweise... Das ist Amerika, ne? Ich glaube, die Amis schenken das zur Geburt von Kindern.
Das kenne ich unter Absteppen oder so.
Genau, und das ist natürlich ein wirklich großer Trend, was so beim Nähen angeht, diese Decken zu nähen. Die Stoffe dafür sind teilweise auch extrem teuer. Aus unerfindlichen Gründen allerdings. Und viele kaufen sich dann halt diese High-End-Maschinen von Benina, damit du halt noch irgendwelche Initialen da eindrucken kannst. Hallluja, das teuerste Modell von Benina kostet nur 9000 Euro.
Oh, was ist denn das rechts unten Modell? Also Achterserie, da gibt es auch nur genau einen Modell. Das ist eine Ansage. So, das ist das High-End, rechts unten Spitzmodell, mit den meisten Funktionen für den höchsten Komfort.
Wow, Stichtesigner steht da, das heißt, du kannst deine Nähmaschine programmieren, dass du dir Stiche definierst. Also der normale Stich ist irgendwie geradeaus oder zigzag als Beispiel und da kannst du halt wirklich Sachen selber definieren, wie dein Stich auszusehen hat, dass du, was weiß ich, da Blumen sticken kannst oder Metaebene am laufenden Band sticken kannst. Ja, das dachte ich mir.
Formdesigner, Farbrad. Ach, der macht dann auch noch mit mehreren Farben.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du das Ding mit deiner Apple Watch noch kombinieren, das würde mich auch nicht wundern.
Verzerrung. 9000 Euro, das ist eine Ansage. Ich find das geil.
Der Touchscreen mit irgendwie allem möglichen Schi-Schi. Ganz ehrlich, es ist krass.
Es ist einfach nur krass.
Einstieg. Was ist der Einstieg? Die Classic Series.
Ja, ich weiß nicht ob die Classic Series. Ich dachte eigentlich, dass die mal günstiger gewesen war. Also das ist diese grundsolide, ganz einfache Nähmaschine. Aber für 1400 fast, die war schon mal günstiger, würde ich meinen.
Da kann man schon direkt mal auf das nächste Modell. Also die 5er-Serie hat doch 2 gekostet.
Also ich denke auch, die 2er-Serie ist auch noch dazwischen. Also es kommt ja auch immer drauf an, was man machen will. Also es muss ja auch echt nicht gleich so eine teure Bänder sein.
Aber Tim will Bändern gleich rechts unten.
Das ist richtig.
Naja, also 9000 Euro würde ich jetzt sicherlich nicht anlegen. Aber ich finde, das geht nicht. Es muss schon irgendwie, also sagen wir mal so, wenn ich jetzt Werkzeug kaufe für das Heim oder auch für den Garten, dann finde ich einfach die Regel, wer billig kauft, kauft zweimal. Das trifft einfach immer zu. Es macht keinen Sinn, den Spaten zu kaufen, der irgendwie fünf Euro billiger ist oder zehn Euro billiger ist. Das ist einfach Blödsinn, weil das Ding fallt sich einfach irgendwann zusammen, wenn du da mal ordentlich auf eine Wurzel drauf haust oder sonst was. Und das geht einfach immer genauso weiter, egal was du heutzutage machst. Und gerade so was wie Nähen und Stricken, ich meine, da geht es mal echt um Präzision. Und gut, so viel Erfahrung habe ich nun auch schon mit Nähmaschinen. Klar, das ist sehr einfach, dass sich das Ding irgendwie zerfleddert und der Faden sich selber auffrisst und du dann nur noch irgendwie so eine Wurst von Müll hast. Warum soll ich damit meine Zeit vergehäuten? Also das macht nun keinen Sinn. Vor allem, und das ist so ein bisschen, jetzt weiß ich wieder, was das beste Vergleich ist, billige Rollschuhe. Inline Skates. Inline Skates. Ich blute ja dann immer, wenn ich immer so irgendwelche 10-jährigen Kinder so mit ihren frisch geschenkten Rollschuhen, also Inline Skates, und dann gucke ich die Dinger. Man muss immerhin sagen, mittlerweile gibt es nicht mehr so richtig schlechte. Also der Standard hat sich insgesamt auch bei den Billigdingern so weit gehoben, dass man sagen kann, okay, da kann man jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so komplett ins Klo greifen. Aber das war vor ein paar Jahren noch echt anders, wo du wirklich diesen Ding angesehen hast. Sie hatten noch Grate irgendwie. Und dann tut mir das immer so in der Seele weh, weil ich weiß, dieses Kind wird unmöglich die Freude dieses Sports überhaupt erfassen können, weil es einfach vollkommen frustriert davon ist, dass die Lager nicht rollen, dass das einfach gar nicht so funktioniert, dass du da keine Passform hast, wo sich der Fuß halbwegs wohlfühlt. Und dann schenke ich doch sowas lieber nicht, als da einfach so eine komplette Vision mit zu zerstören.
Das gleiche gilt für Musikinstrumente, wo dann immer die Eltern sagen, ja, also erst mal so was bewegest, weil wenn es dann nicht will, dann... Und das ist auch total falsch, weil du auch bei einer Gitarre oder so ein unspielbares Ding hast, wo du gegen kämpfen oder für jeden Ton kämpfen musst. Das macht auf jeden Fall keinen Spaß. Und der Trugschluss ist ja teures Instrument, dann hat man das und so. Ein teures Instrument, das ist dann qualitativ so gut, das kannst du auch wieder weiter verkaufen, ohne allzu große Verluste zu machen, wohingegen du diese billige Gitarre auf jeden Fall auf den Müll kloppen kannst. Also man kriegt halt ein gutes Instrument ja auch wieder verkauft. Und wenn man da drüber nachdenkt, also dann, ich meine, das was du für die Rollschuhe sagst, gilt auch für die Instrumente, so durch die ganzen asiatischen Fertigungs-Improvements des letzten Jahrzehnts, der letzten Jahrzehnte ist die Qualität auch für die günstigen Instrumente sehr stark nach oben gegangen. Aber man sollte halt wirklich nicht so jetzt beim Lidl oder so gefühlt vom Grappelregal irgendeine Akustikgitarre nehmen und sagen so hier bitte schön, mach mal. Und wenn nicht, dann nicht, sondern so ein gewisses Mindestmaß an Qualität auch da beim ersten Versuch am Kinde nehmen, genauso wie mit der Nähmaschine.
Ich habe nämlich eine Nähmaschine mal bekommen, das war so bevor ich ausgezogen bin. Und das war halt echt so ein schlechtes Modell, dass ich fast aufgehört habe zu nähen, weil es keinen Spaß mehr gemacht hat. Und jemand hat gerade gefragt nach der Erfahrung mit selbst hergestellten Kleidern versus gekauften Kleidern. Also man darf natürlich nicht den Fehler machen und versuchen, seine Arbeitsleistung dazu berechnen. Als Beispiel, also das, was du da machst, das dauert halt echt lange. Oder es dauert länger, gerade am Anfang musst du dir halt ein bisschen mehr Zeit nehmen. Aber ich merke jetzt schon so, selbst wenn ich teure Stoffe kaufe, also das teuerste an Stoff kauf ich ist Merino, weil ich diesen Stoff von den Eigenschaften halt einfach so sehr liebe, weil ich damit Sport machen kann, aber auch mit dem Kleid sieht das irgendwie noch nett aus. Du sparst halt schon extrem viel Geld, also ich merke das schon. Und was dann halt auch die Lebensdauer der Klamotten angeht, natürlich kommt das so ein bisschen drauf an, wie du sie pflegst, sag ich mal. Und ich merke, dass ich meine Klamotten, die ich kaufe, nicht so sehr pflege, wie ich meine Klamotten hege und pflege, die ich selber mache. Aber im Schnitt, je nachdem, wie gute Qualität der Stoff hat, also ich glaube, das Kleidungsstück, was jetzt am ältesten ist, dürfte und wirklich sehr, sehr häufig getragen wird, so fünf Jahre alt sein, das ist ein Kleid. Fünf Jahre, würde ich fast sagen, es ist mein ältestes, was wirklich aber gefühlt im Sommer gerade, auch eigentlich im Winter, einmal die Woche getragen wird.
Was du selber gemacht hast?
Was ich selber gemacht habe. Na, es hält schon seit fünf Jahren. Also und ich würde sagen, Kleidung, die du kaufst, je nachdem, wie gut die Qualität ist, es hält nicht so lange. Also gerade bei Kleidern habe ich nie so gute Erfahrungen gemacht. Oder dass dann halt die Stoffe irgendwie komisch werden.
Ich trage halt so selten Kleider, aber das ist nicht so richtig. Ich hatte früher mal so einen schönen schottischen Kilt. Den habe ich geliebt. Aber dann habe ich ihn leider unsachgemäß weggelagert. Da kam er dann nur noch in zermotteten Fetzen. Leider aus dem Schrank. Das war traurig. So ein Rock ist schon geil.
Ja, definitiv.
Da habt ihr uns echt was voraus.
Kannst du auch anziehen.
Ich finde auch, Berlin muss nicht mal ein Schottenrock sein.
Ja, man müsste irgendwie genauso... Ich habe noch nicht so richtig drüber nachgedacht.
Oder so Maxi-Kleid. Das ist gerade jetzt im Sommer ultra praktisch.
Was ist denn ein Maxi-Kleid?
Ich liege einfach nur so einen riesen Teil. Maxi-Kleider sind Kleider, die... Oben sind es ja einfach bodenlange Kleider in der Regel. Sie können gerade geschnitten sein, also so eine A-Linie haben. Oder aber einen Full Circle, was ist denn das in Deutsch? Weiß ich nicht. Ausladend Kreis. Hier Rock'n'Roll-Kleider sind diese Full Circle Squirts. Genau, und das sind Maxi-Kleider einfach nur, die einfach sommerlich sind, weit ausladend.
Verstehe.
Und du halt da nicht so drin schwitzt. Also die sehen zwar jetzt so aus, weil sie lang sind, dass du irgendwie ein bisschen schwitzen würdest, aber meistens sind sie halt entweder so ausladend, dass sie schön im Wind flattern und du eigentlich denkst, du läufst nackt durch die Straße. Oder aber du hast einen Schlitz an der Seite und das sorgt für die nötige Belüftung.
Ey Mädels, also diese textile Bandbreite, die ihr da pflegt, das ist irgendwie auch schon echt enorm. Aber es hindert dich ja keiner dran.
So ein Maxi-Kleid zu tragen, nee auf jeden Fall nicht.
Aber wo tue ich denn da hin, aber dann muss ich ja auch mit Handtaschen anfangen. Hab ich ja keine Hosentasche.
Nein, dann kann ich zum Sport-BH empfehlen. Das hatten wir schon mal in der Saison.
Achso, klar, Sport-BH. Weil ich suche nach Maxi-Kleid für Herren, aber im Rhythmus kommt trotzdem nur Damen.
Ich finde, Tim, du solltest mal einen Trend setzen.
Ich finde, du solltest dir mal ein Maxi-Kleid nähen.
Wie mach ich mich zum Followers? Ja, okay, naja, also ich denke mal über den Sport.
Irgendwann muss ich mal unauffällig Maß nehmen bei Tim.
Guck mal, da kommt doch der richtige Tipp, hier gucke mal. Kills mit Taschen. Männer wollen Taschen haben. Frauen wollen auch Taschen haben. Aber warum habt ihr die welche?
Nein, ich hab immer...
Sport BH, was hast du denn da alles drin?
Mein Telefon auf jeden Fall.
Geld geht auch.
Ja, Geld geht auch. Und an dem... Ja, naja, das ist die Advanced-Variante mit dem Sport BH, mit dem Ding sie hinten fürs Telefon.
Ach, da zieht man das Telefon so über den Rücken so raus wie ein Schwert. Wie ein Schwert, ja. Utilikills. Das sieht ja cool aus. Das hier.
Aus Schlumpfhausen, bitte sehr.
Ist das jetzt hier irgendwie Europa oder ist das dieses andere Land? Na gut, aber da kann man ja mal dran arbeiten. Find ich auf jeden Fall cool. Nicht schlecht. Nicht schlecht. Hat was. Also für den Sommer. Also ich hatte, äh, ups. Ähm, lassen wir das. Ich glaub, wir haben jetzt auch den Textilbereich ordentlich durchgediskutiert. Wie sind wir denn überhaupt in der Zeit? Wow, wir haben schon ganz schön weit fortgeschritten. Haben wir noch irgendwelche Themen, die wir unbedingt ansprechen sollten? Jetzt hatten wir nur noch das hier. Eigentlich.
Ja, ich hab mich auch schon abgeregt.
Können wir auch skippen? Wir können uns noch was wünschen. Nächste Woche ist auch hier.
Was ist nächste Woche?
Mit Keynote und so. Geht dir das auch schon so? Was soll schon kommen?
Was soll schon kommen? Also APFS für macOS vielleicht. Das wird kommen. Aber ansonsten... Also ich wählt mir natürlich dann irgendwie diesen Ticker. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das Video mittlerweile mittlerweilig erträge, aber...
Bierchen aufmachen. Drinking Game vereinbaren. Immer wenn sie awesome sagen oder amazing oder unprecedented oder so, dann musst du einen Schluck nehmen. Das wäre mal ganz cool. So ein WWDC-Drinking Game, das gibt es doch bestimmt schon alles im Internet.
Also ich würde mir auf jeden Fall natürlich, also wenn ich mir wünschen würde, MacBook Pro 15 Zoll mit wieder Hardware-Tasten, mit Keyboard-Revision 2 und SIM-Karten-Slot. Ja, wobei mittlerweile...
Die Hoffnung haben wir schon lange aufgegeben, ne?
Mittlerweile ist mir der gar nicht mehr so wichtig.
Doch, nichts nervt mich mehr.
Es gibt doch überall Wi-Fi. Oder nicht?
Guck mal, hier ist ein schönes Drinking-Git. Drink every time somebody says incredible.
Also ich nehme auch einen SIM-Karten-Slot, so ist es nicht. Auch stürzen. Consume drink in large gulps.
Drink every time it's just the beginning. Drink every time Apple is modest about their product design. Finish your drink every time the audience is unsure about it. Drink every time somebody mentions China. Chuck every time a woman is spotted on stage.
Na ja, das ist ja in letzter Zeit besser geworden.
Das hat deutlich zugenommen, würde ich sagen. Und so weiter. Keyboard. Ja, so richtig, das ist es nicht. Bono, das weiß ich nicht unbedingt. Ich weiß auch nicht so richtig, was ich erwarten soll davon. Aber ich habe Hoffnung. Erstmal habe ich die Hoffnung, dass Mac OS endlich in Nummer 11 umgetauscht wird. Das fände ich jetzt mal irgendwie gut, wenn sie jetzt sagen... Ich meine, iOS 11 kommt, irgendwie Watch OS heißt, nee, ist 3, aber was anderes auch noch.
Woanders zählen sie die Major-Version auf jeden Fall fröhlich weiter.
Ich meine, was soll denn das?
Naja, geht bis 99, ne?
Jetzt wäre die Zeit einfach zu sagen, OS 10 ist over, jetzt heißt es einfach Mac OS 11. Mac OS 11, bitte, einmal. Einmal richtige Tastaturen, bitte, wird nicht kommen, aber wünschen können wir uns das ja mal. Überhaupt ist, glaube ich, dieses Buch irgendwie verkackt, oder?
Kanten bitte wieder normal machen und nicht so krass scharf.
Das haben sie auch noch gemacht.
Also ich finde, wirklich mit der Tastatur und der Option, Function Keys, also die normalen Tasten wieder zu haben, statt der Touchbar, damit würden sie das Gerät schon sehr stark aufwerten.
Aufwertung durch Rückschritt.
Und das Touchpad könnte auch gerne wieder ein bisschen kleiner sein. Das ist wirklich unnötig groß. Und ansonsten...
Stört das?
Achso, und die Tastenmechanik halt, weil du hast halt irgendwie...
Man kommt die ganze Zeit drauf.
Man kann halt, wenn man so da drauf lungert und mal die Hand ablegt, dann plötzlich löst man irgendwas aus oder man drückt eine Taste, und dann ist aber noch was auf dem Touchpad und das verhält sich plötzlich wie einen Kontextklick oder solche Sachen halt. Also du hast halt nicht genug Resting Space für deine Flossen.
Das Ding ist echt ein Trainwreck. Ich verstehe das überhaupt nicht, dass sie damit irgendwie schon wieder Zusächse haben. Ich glaube, viele haben sich das gekauft, weil sie dachten so, oh geil, mal was Neues, endlich mal wieder irgendwas. Und dann so, alles ist schlechter.
Dass die Tastatur halt kaputt geht. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, bei IKEA, wenn du da früher reingegangen bist, da hatten sie ja irgendwie ihre Stühle da und so ein Roboter, der die ganze Zeit irgendwie gegen die Lehne dengelt, um zu zeigen, ne, der ist stabil, der ist stabil, der hält, ne. Ich meine, wie lange haben sie denn diese Tastatur getestet? Das kann doch nicht sein, dass jetzt bei allen Leuten da die Keys kaputt gehen. Ich bin ja einer, der immer ein externes Keyboard anschließt, weswegen ich wahrscheinlich noch keine Probleme habe. Aber der Kollege, der das halt einfach so als tägliches Hackbrett auch benutzt, das kann doch nicht sein, dass das auseinanderfisselt da.
Ja, vor allem ohne Not.
Ohne Not.
Das war wirklich die geilste Tastatur, die je ein Laptop gesehen hat. Und dann machen sie das kaputt für einen Millimeter Bauhöhe oder so. Und irgendwie, ich hätte auch ganz gern mal so ein Mac OS, was es den Leuten einfach macht, mal dieses System irgendwie in den Griff zu kriegen, dass dieses ganze Kaputtnudeln einfach nicht mehr da ist.
Na, wäre ja immer auch interessant, was sie überhaupt für User Interfaces dann für Apple File System anbieten. Ob dann so Time Machine und Snapshots und so Zeug irgendwie da auch so schön reinwandert, ne?
Das muss auf jeden Fall sein. Und ich wäre auch bereit für so ein komplett neues API. Einfach mal Anwendungen ganz neu machen. So ein bold move, so ein... Das alte Konzept ist jetzt alt und jetzt gibt es was Neues. Und alles wird gut, wie immer bei Apple, wenn was Neues kommt.
Also ehrlich gesagt...
Won't happen. Wir lassen uns einfach überraschen und dann können wir das ja nochmal durchquatschen in unserer 200. Sendung, die wir ohne großes Brimborium und Klimbim machen. Vielleicht ihr da draußen, vielleicht gibt euch das ja irgendwie mehr. Und wenn ihr irgendwie gute Ideen habt zu 200, dann lasst es regnen. Wir haben jetzt keine besonderen Pläne, weil die nächste Zeit, wir nähern uns ja auch so dem Sommer.
Dem Sommerloch.
Ich bin schon ganz excited. Ich will so richtig Sommer haben dieses Jahr. Nach diesem Winter. Je älter man wird, umso mehr sehnt man sich nach Sommer. Das ist wirklich strange. Irgendwann verstehe ich auch, warum die ganzen Rentner die ganze Zeit nur noch irgendwie auf Mallorca abhängen. Schon nachvollziehbar.
Kann man auch so schon ganz gut machen. Ich wollte noch nicht auch gerade sagen, so alt sind wir jetzt nur nicht.
Michaela hat ja auch den Bogen raus. Die weiß ja, wie das geht mit der Arbeitsvirtualisierung und so. Michaela, vielen Dank fürs Kommen. War gar nicht so schlimm, oder? Mit Stricken geht's.
Wollen wir noch mal über nächste Woche reden? Nächstes Wochenende?
Genau.
Deswegen hab ich diese Party verpasst.
Mein Fehler, Huckel, mein Fehler.
Gut, heute mal ein ganz anderes Themenfeld, so wie immer. Und insofern haben wir noch einen Bonus-Track? Nein, haben wir nicht, ne? Wir sagen einfach Tschüss und bis bald.
Winke, winke. Und wir sehen uns bald!